Hello, hello!
Welcome!
Welcome to Rust Kingdoms.
So, I am in the Lurk Lands right now.
So, if you guys don't know, I have an exclusive Twitch drop.
So, what that means is that... I want to say a huge thank you to Abe and Sykkuno.
Abe went to Sykkuno telling him he had an exclusive Twitch drop and he asked Sykkuno, like, who do you want to be?
Because you're supposed to partner up for the Twitch drop.
And Sykkuno was like, I want to have a Twitch drop... I want to have a Rust drop with Doki.
So, a huge shoutout to Sykkuno for just suggesting me and giving me an opportunity to have a gun skin.
We get to pick whatever items we wanted.
And Sykkuno was like, we have to get an AK gun.
We have... because I didn't know anything about Rust, because I was like...
I was like, oh wait, like, what do we... what should we get?
Because we could get a skin for anything we want.
And Sykkuno was like, oh, we should do an... we should get an AK.
And I was like, why?
And he's like, the AK in Rust is the best gun in the game.
So...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
No, wait, no!
No!
I've been fucked!
I had... I had so...
Where am I?
Where the fuck... oh my god!
Okay, back, I'm getting my stuff back.
Okay, give me a second, I'm gonna try...
I just... I just tried to talk!
Anyway... anyway...
I have to go back to Lurklands!
I had so much wood!
You don't understand!
I had so much...
I had... I had so...
I had so much wood!
You don't understand!
I was farming the wood!
Because I was allowed to be on the server 30 minutes early, because I have a drop.
So I was like, yippee!
I'm gonna farm so much wood!
Oh my god, give me a sec, I have like something that keeps like popping in and out.
Like, what the fuck is it?
Oh...
So, anyway...
Anyway...
Let me go back, what was I saying?
Okay, so...
What the fuck is it?
Oh, it's my fucking...
Anyway, so...
So, Sekuro suggested me to be part of the exclusive Twitch drops.
And we wanted some, you know...
A lot of the other people, they made like drops that were more generic.
So like, you know...
People who might not know the streamer would want the drop.
But because like...
I know like, this is my...
Uh...
This is my like, very first rust drop.
And uh...
So, and Sekuro wanted something that was branded towards our fans!
So that's why, uh...
I was in charge of finding the artist for the gun.
And um...
You know, at first, apparently like...
It was supposed to be like...
One different item per streamer.
So like, each streamer who has a drop gets a different item.
But you might have noticed...
Me, Saekun and I...
And xQc and Trainwrecks...
Both are AK skins.
Um...
Because we didn't know the other claimed AK as well.
And it was funny because like...
Apparently, Train's pair claimed it first.
But we didn't know.
But we already commissioned the artist and everything.
So, we were like, begging Abe.
We were like, Abe, please!
Let us have...
Our fanbases don't even overlap!
Abe, please!
And then we were sending...
We were sending him like, sad cat videos.
We were like, meow, meow, meow, meow!
And like, begging like, please!
We already commissioned the artist!
We can't go back!
We can't!
We can't just tell the artist to draw something else!
Please!
We worked so hard!
And...
We were just sending him sad cat videos.
Please!
Let us have our AK!
That is why...
That's why there's two AK skins.
That's why there's...
Because we were like, please!
We already worked so hard!
We were like...
We were both sending him sad cat videos.
Wait, what the...
Speaking...
Saekuno!
Goodbye!
Alright, goodbye!
Alright!
That's the drive-by.
I guess he...
He didn't see me.
I was like, wait!
Speaking of Saekuno...
Goodbye, Saekuno!
Anyway...
What a drive-by.
Flashbang by a naked...
A naked running man.
It was so...
No, it was working because I was talking to somebody else.
Woah!
Woah, woah, woah!
I just...
I just got...
I...
Please, please spare me.
I don't have anything.
I was born naked and afraid.
Yeah, but I was born especially naked and afraid.
I had no hair on me when I was born.
What?
They just got kidnapped?
Am I supposed to come along?
Am I part of it?
Okay, okay!
Wait, but I left my bow back there!
It was a really good bow.
Woah!
Oh my god!
I guess I got kidnapped.
I got kidnapped to the mines.
Woah, woah.
It just stopped moving.
Can I...
Oh!
It didn't save me!
Wait, did everybody get that?
Well...
I'm free now.
Did everyone else got DC'd or was it just me?
Oh, it was just me.
It was just me!
They'll never...
Sorry, I just realized.
I realized that...
Wait.
Why can't I connect back?
Wait a minute.
What the f...
Do I have to restart?
Oh, I think I need to restart my game, right?
Okay, wait.
Wait, do I need to restart?
Oh no, I'm gabbed.
His mic was so fucking crunchy!
What is he saying?
I don't know.
You have to message me on Discord, Sound Guy.
Because I can't see you on here.
I can't see.
It was so crunchy.
I had to lock in to figure out what the fuck he was saying.
Oh my god, I'm alive again.
Okay, I still love how Sykkuno just literally did a drive-by and he just disappeared.
Alright, okay, I'm safe.
Alright, back to...
Back to my bow!
I will get my bow!
They won't know.
Saved by the DC!
Alright.
What do you do?
Oh my god.
So yeah.
So I think if you connect your Steam account...
Also, this is one of the newest things.
So it's like a coliseum where you can challenge people.
So the whole premise of Rice Kingdoms is that there's a couple of leaders around here.
So you can see, it's like Game of Thrones, basically.
So there's House Dragonclaw, House Poggerion, and then there's one more.
I think there's four kingdoms.
Oh my god, I'm almost there.
I hope the pig is not there.
I really want my bow back.
I just want my bow back!
And to get the drops, you just need to connect your you just need to connect your Steam to I think like to Twitch or something and then you should be able to get it.
And you just need to watch a little bit.
So, it is a little bit unfortunate timing for me regarding Rice Kingdoms because next week I won't be at home.
So...
So I just gotta I'll try to stream Rust as much as I can before I go, which is like in three days.
I mean, I can try and stream Rust while I'm away.
I can have my laptop.
So the first three days is the most we're gonna get of Rust.
Uh...
Are you part of the house?
I am part of...
Wait, is this it?
What is this?
Why is it glowing?
Oh, to harvest it faster.
Okay.
Well, that's new.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can aim.
Alright.
Give me that rock.
I don't know how to play Rust.
I'm just a role player.
I'm just...
Oh, it's not new.
Why is it glowing?
I've never seen a rock glow like that before.
When did they put that in?
Oh my god, please.
I'm gonna accidentally hit my dick.
If you harvest you, I'm gonna accidentally hit my dick if I keep doing this with my rock.
Just a naked man and his rock.
Alright.
I don't know.
I think there's a lot of people on this server too.
I know this time around there's a lot more.
There's a lot of big... Where did I die?
Oh, please tell me my stuff is still here.
Where the fuck did I die?
I got knocked off by a fucking boar.
Alright, there.
Where's my body?
Please, all I want is one thing and it's that giant ass bow.
I just want my bow back.
That's all.
Please.
I had a bow.
It had no arrows, but I like that I had it.
It looked threatening.
That's all I wanted.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm right here.
Where did I die?
How did I die?
I'm here.
I thought this was me.
This is me, by the way.
This is me.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I thought this was me right there.
I'm gonna take this away.
That actually confused the shit out of me.
I'm sorry, veteran Rust players.
I'm so sorry.
This is how it's gonna be for the first three days.
Yes, I got that Rust Twitch strap.
Yes, veteran Rust players.
I am the one you have to watch to get your gun.
That's right.
You gotta watch this gameplay now.
Alright.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Okay, thank god.
That's good.
I got all I needed.
Oh my gosh, I'm ginger.
The biggest crime.
Oh my god, there he is again.
There he is.
I need a cat.
Get me outta here.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I usually...
Gumi held my hand last time.
So now I'm like, what do I...
Oh my god, he has a...
This guy has a fucking horse?
How?
I don't even...
I don't have anything.
Wait, there's a bunch of people there.
Wait, I'm starving.
I'm starving.
How do I get food?
Oh no, am I gonna die of hunger now?
I'm scared.
There's a lot of people there.
Oh my god, what if I die?
There's mushrooms?
Okay, I don't want them to see me.
How do I get food?
I gotta scavenge.
Find mushrooms?
There's mushrooms here?
I'm gonna message Gumi.
She'll hold my hand again.
She actually was gonna hold my hand.
But I got in first.
Okay, wait.
I'll message her.
I am in the lurk lands.
Okay, also...
Okay, wait.
I almost leaked something.
Oh yeah, by the way...
Doobie will be a guest at the Phantom Thief concert.
That was what I almost leaked yesterday.
Not yesterday.
That was what I almost leaked on Minecraft.
During the hardcore plays.
I almost...
That was the one where Mint was like, Woah, woah, woah, Doki!
So yeah, she will be...
She will be a guest at the...
At the Phantom Thief concert in December.
It was a surprise for me too when I found out.
She was like a...
Last minute addition.
And I'm really happy that she was...
So yeah, she's gonna be doing a song with us.
With me and Mint.
So we're gonna have like a...
A song and dance together.
As well at the concert.
But yeah, I'm super excited.
Alright, what do you make first?
What do you...
Make first in Rust?
Oh my god, I still need to find food.
I need to find food.
Alright, guys.
I need to figure out...
Oh, fucking hell.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
I have nothing on me.
I am not a threat.
I don't even have a spear.
All I have is this.
Oh, for me?
Oh, it's empty.
Oh, thanks man.
Oh, you do?
Are you a trash cleaner?
Yeah, sure.
Do you have food on you?
Yeah, I'm a trash cleaner.
Is it like...
Oh my god, thanks man.
I found this in the trash can.
Oh my god.
It could be very moldy, so be careful.
You know, food's food, you know.
Wait, so how did you get started being a trash cleaner?
Well...
It all started when I first woke up.
Like...
Oh...
So you're an orphan.
Were you raised by like the raccoons?
Yeah, like what?
Like what?
What did you do?
Hey...
You know what man?
I bet that old lady's dead anyway.
Okay...
What's she gonna do with two million dollars?
You have more to live.
I got more to live.
Exactly, you have more years.
You knew how to spend that two million dollars well.
I mean, you lost it all, but like...
She would have just not done anything with it.
You know how I lost it all?
You know how I lost all my money?
I gambled two million dollars?
On voting?
Yeah, no, he's a garbage man.
He's a garbage man.
You're voting what?
He's a gambling garbage man.
He's an addict.
He has a problem.
He's also an orphan.
I'm a prom dumpster baby, okay?
Don't forget that.
Yeah, he is the prom dumpster baby.
I didn't realize there was prom here in the kingdoms.
There's prom in the kingdoms?
How do you guys, how do you eat?
Oh, there it is.
Now I'm not hungry again.
Yeah?
Do it.
Wait, no, he gave me tuna.
Wait, he gave me tuna.
He's just a little, he's just a little guy.
Maybe we should keep him as a pet.
I can't wait.
Wait a minute.
If dumpster man can hear this meow right now.
I don't think he hears.
He's just trying to find his trash.
Wait, how do you have all that stuff?
I don't know how to play.
Wait, there's another person over there.
Who's that?
Hello!
It's lady Dima.
Whoa!
What's that over there?
Do you have trash?
This is our local trash cleaner.
I need your trash.
I have a rock.
Alright, let's go find food.
I'll find food with you.
I have a bow with zero arrows.
Oh shit, what do you need to make arrows?
I can, I can, I can make you some.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, I'm a professional.
I can aim.
I was trained to be an aimer.
Trust me.
Oh, you want me to log out right now and change it?
I can log out right now and change my Steam name.
Oh, wait.
Let me turn up the volume a bit more.
Whoa!
Oh shit, sorry!
Sorry.
No, no, don't.
I'm just looting.
Wait.
What did I do?
No, sorry.
We don't.
We're collecting trash as well right now.
To find food.
Wait.
Okay, over here.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I just realized I can't break the box.
What's going on?
Oh, don't tell me I DC'd again.
Get ready, guys.
Okay.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll get kicked out soon.
What?
It still says I'm connected.
While the server fixes itself...
Oh, I'm gonna fix the volume.
I'll fix myself too.
Oh shit!
Wait, what happened?
Oh, I'm out.
I think there's something up with the server.
I don't think I've had issues...
That many issues before.
I don't think I got that.
Is anyone else DCing too?
Or is it just me?
I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, Gumi did as well?
Oh, it's not me.
I think it's the server.
I know that.
Yeah, thank God.
I'm not the problem.
Thankfully, I'm not the problem.
Yeah!
Hello?
Yeah, did you guys all DC too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I DCed earlier as well.
I think the server is just weird today.
It's just technical difficulties.
Alright, back to farming.
Alright.
No, we don't.
We're sadly...
We got food from the garbage man.
You might be able to find him.
He's out there.
Yeah.
Go over that way, and then you'll find the garbage man.
He's out there giving people garbage.
What happened to be food?
Yeah, he gave me a tuna can.
It was moldy, but it was pretty good tuna.
Oh, you're gonna die?
Wait, if you're dying, can I get XP?
Can I get XP if you're gonna die?
Can I get XP?
You're gonna die anyway, right?
Nice.
XP.
Yeah, are you gonna die?
Are you gonna...
You're not starving, right?
What's your starve meter?
Do you want to join your friend?
You don't care about her?
You don't care about your friend?
Oh, we're your friends now?
Oh, so you don't care about her.
Oh!
So you're...
Oh, you don't even...
You're not a real friend!
You're not real!
You're not loyal!
Alright, nice.
Let's go.
You would never...
Yeah, of course.
I would die fighting for you.
Just for you.
Nice.
Hey, I got XP.
Wait, Gumi, do you get XP from Rust?
Oh yeah, we can eat her!
We can eat her!
Nice.
Oh, we should've fed her to her friend!
We should've fed her...
We could've been like, hey, you're hungry.
We can't...
It was a total waste.
We got food.
Oh!
We can barbecue at the beach!
Oh my god, we can cook right now.
Let's cook her meat.
Wait, I have meat too!
I have fingers!
Alright.
Let me put my finger in here too.
Maybe we'll just be cannibals.
It's not that bad.
Wait, I just realized we weren't supposed to kill people.
Well, I just realized...
Oh no, now I'm a bandit.
I'm a bandit now.
No!
I can't believe it!
Okay, I'm coming back.
I can't believe...
Are you serious?
Alright, where was I?
Where did I die?
Oh my god!
Alright.
Let's go.
Off we go.
It's fine.
No, I'm still a bandit.
No!
My barbecue!
Oh my god.
I can't believe...
A bear of all things?
Oh my god.
What's that over there?
Wait.
Hello.
Oh no, no, no.
It was a bear.
I was trying to fight a bear.
And then, like, my partner...
Was beside me and I suddenly hit her.
And so the bear and I lost everything.
I am nothing now.
I swear, I'm not evil.
I'm not an evil man.
It was all the bear's fault.
Are you sure about that?
Yes, I'm sure.
This is all I have.
If I was an evil man, why would I be naked?
Actually, no, that makes more sense.
But if I was an evil man...
If I was really evil, would I be ginger?
Okay, no, that's not helping.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, okay.
If I was an evil man...
Why would I let you live?
Exactly.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I have a very long pilgrimage back to where I died.
It's like...
Yeah, I'll see...
I died back at like...
K7.
I had to go back.
We were having...
We were having a little barbecue session.
Of like the animals we killed.
And then a bear showed up out of nowhere.
It was like...
Was that the bear cartoon?
Where we were at the picnic?
It's just like that.
Oh, wait.
Were you talking when you had your map open?
Yeah.
Oh!
I died at K7.
Wait, wait.
That's a while away.
Yeah, I'll see you later.
Thank you for the ore.
I really appreciate it.
Just remember, I'm not evil.
I might be ginger, but I'm not evil.
I swear.
Good luck with the rest of your travels.
Alright.
Off we go.
Gumi lived?
Of course I didn't see the chat.
I was having a fucking conversation.
Also, I hope the volume is okay.
I got a message.
Is this from Sound Guy?
Um, alright.
It was.
Okay.
I hope the sound was better.
She killed the bear?!
Alright, off we go.
Off we go.
Look, I...
I got ganked!
Out of...
How was I supposed to live?
How the fuck was I supposed to be alive?
I literally got shot first!
I got hit first!
Oh my god, this is so far.
This is the pilgrimage of death.
I got ganked from the jungle.
Oh my god, it's like deadlock all over again.
The fucking Vindicta jumped up in the air and fucking shot me.
There's another bear.
No, please.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Got
me!
No!
The bear got the gun!
Please be a closer respawn.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Back to the pilgrimage.
Why is it so far?
Do not...
Oh my god, ever since I killed that one... Oh, it's cause I'm abandoned!
No!
I'm abandoned!
That's why!
I just remember why.
Oh my god.
It's cause I'm...
I'm marked.
I'm marked for dead.
Oh my god.
I'm re-rolling.
Off do I go.
I just wanted...
We were hungry.
We were starving.
I just wanted...
I just...
We just needed food.
She was gonna die anyway!
She was gonna die!
What was I supposed to do?
It was literally free food.
It was... Oh my god, it's so dark.
Free real estate.
Oh yeah, I should... I don't wanna wait.
I don't wanna... Alright, here we go.
Just so I can at least see it.
The...
Oh my god.
Just so I can see the big, great pilgrimage of 2024.
Maybe I could steal somebody's horse.
Maybe... Maybe there would be a horse nearby.
Woah!
Watch out, my lord!
Okay, there's like...
There's shots over there.
Woah, spawn more at night?
Don't say that.
I am like...
30 squares away.
I'm 30 squares away.
Don't say that.
Oh my god, there's the church.
Maybe they'll have shelter for me.
Maybe the church people will take me in for the night.
Wait.
Maybe...
Oh my god.
I'm a good person.
It was self-defense.
Oh my god.
No, it's the church.
This is the official Blood God church.
It's very sacred and safe.
Oh my god.
Maybe they'll house me for the night.
Woah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait.
Alright.
Oh.
Alright, let's just...
Guys, I'm poor and I don't want to get scalped.
Guys.
I...
I don't want to get scalped.
I don't want to get scalped, guys.
Anyway, moving along.
Moving along.
Let's head back to our pilgrimage.
I am...
I was at the church.
And I got...
But now, I'm leaving because I heard they scalp...
scalp the poor.
Woah!
Oh god, oh god.
I'm coming over.
That's Rust Kingdom's one doki.
This is Rust Kingdom's two doki.
Hahaha.
Rust Kingdom two doki is different.
I don't know, guys.
Rust Kingdom one...
Rust... Woah!
Rust Kingdom two doki is very poor right now.
Please, I need to go back.
I need to go back.
I didn't realize back then, the blood god was so much nicer.
I didn't get scalped.
The blood god back then didn't scalp me.
No, no.
I wasn't part of the cult.
That was different.
Different.
That was...
Back then, the...
Back then, the blood god cult was more refined.
They, like...
Their practices were really, like, um, flowed with me.
Like, what they were preaching and everything.
They knew what they were preaching.
Now, it's just so commercialized.
Now, the blood god cult just feels so commercialized and, like, they just fell into capitalism and all that.
That just ain't for me.
What happened to the more humble times?
Humble blood god ways?
They ain't chill like that anymore.
It's just different.
It's just not the same.
They sold out.
Yeah, the blood gods sold out.
Yeah, the old grass root blood gods.
Where was Rust Kingdom's one blood god?
The humble blood god.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where was...
Okay, I'm almost there.
Oh my god.
I saw... That's the coliseum again.
There it is.
Oh no.
No!
I...
I'll never make it back.
I'll actually never...
I'll actually never make it back.
I don't...
I give up.
She's gotta come to me.
I...
I'm encountering all the bears.
I don't
understand.
How is it...
Where is the fucking...
Where am I?
Gumi.
I died to a bear three times.
Every time I get close to you a bear a bear shows up.
Every time I get close!
I can't.
I can't do this again.
Come to me.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't.
I can't keep traveling in that area.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Please.
You got this.
I can't.
How did I...
Do I fucking keep finding bears?
Every time.
I'll never make it.
Maybe I should ask for an escort from the blood gods.
Maybe.
Maybe I'll just ask for a fucking escort.
It's a sign to join the blood gods again.
Oh my god.
I'll never be able to make it back home.
I'll never.
I'll never make it back.
Oh my god.
Please.
There's the church again.
There it is.
Hello, kind dude.
I heard you guys helped the needy.
Can you please escort me to my friend?
Can you please?
I've been fucking ganked by three different bears.
Three different bears.
How many bears out there?
Oh my god.
This is because I would enjoy because I killed that one person accidentally out of self-defense.
It's just because, just because I was just putting her out of her, she was gonna die anyway.
It was a mercy killing.
She was literally gonna die anyway.
Like there was no food.
It was terminal.
I just put her out of her misery.
She was gonna starve.
It was a mercy killing.
Oh my god.
This time.
Oh my god, that's a deer.
Oh my god, I swear to god.
That was another fucking bear.
This entire...
I've just been trying to head to this one area.
What the fuck?
Now there's a sermon?
I don't have any scrap.
Scrap?
The fuck?
What?
Fuck this.
I don't fuck with sacrifices, man.
Alright, anyway.
Let's get back to our journey.
That was a nice detour.
That was...
That was a nice detour that we saw there.
We gotta go.
We gotta go back on our journey.
Back to...
Okay, there we go.
We have to leave.
It was a nice little...
It was like those in-game cutscenes.
That you just happen to walk into.
Like...
Like those real-time...
Real-time cutscenes.
Gumi, are you still...
Gumi, are you still in the same...
In the...
In the same place?
The Resident Evil...
You know, like when you're in an MMO.
And then you just happen upon, like...
Not just an MMO.
An RPG game.
And you just happen to walk across an event.
You just walked across to an in-game event.
And you just...
Watch it happen.
I can't believe she's still there.
She's actually...
Yeah, the chance encounter.
Okay, we gotta avoid this spot.
That's where the bears are.
No, don't say that!
I can't keep doing this!
I cannot do Groundhog Day!
I cannot!
I cannot keep doing...
I cannot keep dying!
To this fucking bear!
Everywhere I go...
This bear is out to get...
It's like a canon event.
I eventually have to die to this bear.
Please, not the bear.
Anything but the bear.
Oh my god, we're back.
We're almost there.
All the paths will eventually lead you to the bear.
Every path I take.
No matter where I go.
It's a canon event that I have to die to.
To this god forsaken fucking bear.
Oh, there he is!
But I'm going on the mountain now.
That's fucking right!
You can't get me, you fucking bear.
I see you.
I fucking see you.
I got the mountain on my side this time.
I'd rather get cold...
Than fucking die to a bear.
The only way to beat this cycle...
Is to die to a bear.
Please, I need to get my stuff back.
I can hold alt to look around.
Oh, thank god.
As long as I'm on the mountain...
I won't get attacked.
Don't say that!
It's not a bear, so we're safe.
Also, I hope the sound's been okay so far.
Oh, someone already built a house.
I swear, I spent more of my time trying to find my way back home.
Trying to find my way back to this one area.
Mountain bears.
Don't say that.
I'm done.
I'm so done with these bears.
I'm so fucking done.
Also, can my mods pin messages?
Maybe we should pin the drop on the top of the chat.
So it's more convenient.
For people to see.
So many...
So many bears.
Ever since I killed that one person.
Ever since I mercy killed that person too.
It was literally a mercy kill.
Alright.
I'm heading over.
We're almost there.
We're almost here.
That one person...
Garnet.
It's like when you...
You made fun of the witch for being ugly.
And then the witch puts a curse on you.
And then my curse...
Oh my...
Okay, cool.
I guess I'll starve as well.
The witch...
I'm like the beast.
The witch puts a curse on me.
And the curse is that I'll always die to a bear.
That's my curse.
No, please.
I'm almost there.
I'm literally almost back.
It's right there.
Here it is.
Oh, come on.
I did.
I didn't, but like...
Just for the sake of it.
Did you get his body?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait.
No, please.
No, I'm not a bandit.
I swear to god, please.
Please, I'm not.
I swear to god.
I don't...
No, it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
Oh my god.
Are we going?
I hope so.
I'm trying to find...
I'm trying to find a particular group.
No!
Gobi!
Oh!
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, we're trying to find our friends.
No, he's with me.
He's with me.
He saved my life before.
From the bandit hunters.
He's a good man.
There was a bandit.
Yeah.
Yes.
I got touched by a bear four times.
And I lived.
Well, sort of.
But I'm okay now.
Wait.
Wait,
I'm a little dehydrated.
Does anyone have water?
I went on a long 20 day pilgrimage.
Oh, okay.
I got better.
Kissed by the claws of the bear.
Okay.
I gotta go get some water.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
What were the chances?
If you see any bandits, tell us.
And I'm like, oh, I'm leaving.
What were the odds of that?
What were the odds of that fucking happening to me?
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, thank god.
I'm okay.
I'm okay now.
Alright.
I gotta go back to the lands.
Oh.
Does it sound better now?
I keep asking it because I keep forgetting to check what you guys say.
Perfect timing.
Alright.
Where was the...
Where were the rest of them?
Wait, where were they?
Oh my god, I already got lost.
Where did they go?
I don't even remember.
Oh, there they are.
Hello.
I'm back.
I'm not so sure.
No, no, no.
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm good.
I had to defend myself from other bandits.
But I won.
If boss gives me the green light, I won't do anything.
Pick these up.
Aim at this rock over here.
Aim at this rock, okay.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do I use the bow?
Guys, how do I use...
Someone's arrow went into the ground.
Not me.
Guys, I don't know how to use the bow, guys.
Blow, blow, please.
Wait, I heard of a Sturbingo.
Where is he?
I have acquired a club.
He has extra arrows.
Guys, I've never ridden a bow before.
Do you have an extra arrow?
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
Oh, nice, thanks.
Thank God you're a bad shot.
Thank God.
Oh, there we go.
We did it.
I need food.
Guys, I don't want to get bad.
Where's Goomy?
Oh, there she is.
Do you have extra food, Goomy?
Oh, yeah, yeah, you're right.
Wait, who are these?
Is that fire?
I will take the shot.
Oh, we almost got ran over.
The no one tribe.
We just woke up in the middle of the cold.
And we're trying to find clothing and food and water.
I was trying to escape my life.
You know, the cops got me fucked up, okay?
And this, I just had nothing.
No skin on my back, nothing.
The cops?
Why were the cops after you?
We will clothe you and feed you, as is the way.
Why were the cops?
Don't worry about why the cops are after us.
Rider!
Rider on the road!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Is the server lagging?
OOC, sometimes I don't know what other lines to say.
I have a few that I learned from...
OOC!
I guess we follow him.
Are you guys...
Are you guys in the same boat I am?
Yeah, we're teleporting around.
Sometimes we're OOC.
Are you guys in the same boat I am?
I don't know what's going on.
I guess we just follow him.
Are you guys in the same boat I am?
Break the barrels and farm the resources along the road.
Then when you have enough, do you see that rock in the distance?
That is the Cold Stone Fortress.
Meet us there when you have clothing.
Rangers with me.
Oh, well I've been going around naked.
I'm making you clothing right now.
I'm making you clothing right now, man.
Thank you.
Just like back in Rust Kingdoms 1, I don't have to try.
He wants to be a seamstress.
I think?
Yeah, you think?
What even is our goal anymore?
Oh, I saw him.
I saw a sermon.
Well, I was gonna ask for assistance at the church because I was like, I'm poor.
I need assistance.
I need shelter from the cold night.
And then as I was going to approach the church, they were talking about how they were going to scalp the poor.
And then I was like, wait, I'm the poor.
So, I walked away.
Join us, we lurklings, for we do not kneel and we bow to no king.
We bow to no god.
We acknowledge the old gods, but that's about it.
Who are the old gods?
Yeah, who are the old gods?
Oh, I thought I already wore shoes.
Yeah, I'm already wearing shoes.
Oh, we're just close acquaintances.
We're just work friends.
That's not true.
We're just co-workers.
Oh, my bad.
No, it's alright.
It's okay.
Oh, okay, yeah.
Oh, my god!
It's Sir Adam!
Sir Adam!
Brave warriors, I come back with loot and many stories and tales.
What kind of stories?
Lord Bingle!
What is this?
What kind of stories, Lord Bingle?
Why do you kneel?
We do not kneel!
Okay, we do not kneel.
I'm sorry.
I'm showing respect to our fellow queens.
I'm an ally.
I'm like you, misogynistic freaks.
Oh!
Oh, my bad!
What's going on, y'all?
Why do your name be Red?
Yeah, why is your name Red?
I think it's the faulty brakes.
Faulty brakes.
Travelers with me!
That's all, y'all.
Very interesting.
Sir Adam, is it safe to come out?
Wait, who is this guy, Sir Adam?
Who is he?
Put your hands up!
I have a gun!
I'll shoot right now!
Okay, we'll leave!
Drop your clothes!
You can't aim for shit!
Drop your clothes right now!
Take the shot!
I dare you!
Take the shot right now!
He's gone.
They're gone.
They were too scared to take the shot.
Yeah, they didn't even take the shot!
Fucking cowards!
Not even real!
Where did Sir Elim go?
We do not have a kingdom!
We do not have a king!
We are free people!
Come!
Wait, Sir Elim's gone.
A new soul has entered the blood cauldron.
The Coldstone Fortress?
Oh my god.
Can't wait to see the Coldstone Fortress.
Will I ever get an AK that uses my own skin?
We'll find out.
Imagine we played Rust and we never even get our own...
We never even get an AK!
I'll never... I don't think it'll happen.
First...
If you'll enter our home...
You must first pledge allegiance...
to the Old Gods.
Cast out all other beliefs.
Who are the Old Gods, Sir?
Thank you.
Odin.
The gates of Valhalla will only open...
if you worship Odin.
Have you ever died...
and felt like you could just come back to life?
Have you ever wondered...
I've always dreamed of that.
It's not the Old God, but...
It is not the Blood God.
It is the Old God that gives you that power.
Does he really?
It is the Old God.
The Old Faith.
Guys, Valhalla!
I have done that about seven times.
I was wondering about that.
I can be naked in the permafrost...
and nothing can harm me.
Let him go.
The power of the Old Gods...
are protecting him!
Is this a different cult?
Did the Old Gods build this?
Was this built by the Old Gods as well?
How did they do this?
This rock has been passed down...
many generations.
We've lived here for millennia.
If you have a bow with me...
I need you to arrange you...
naked one.
I have dung.
No, I have clothes on.
That's not me.
You will gather wood for me.
I have a rock.
Am I to invite them...
to our house?
I need to make sure they can provide for us first.
I need to make sure this group of rangers...
is willing to kill when necessary.
I am.
Yes, sir!
Are we going to kill?
Wait, is that Sir Alan?
Archers!
They are procuring the rock!
They are trying to claim the rock!
They stepped foot on my rock!
Get off my sacred rock!
Get off the great rock!
Where did they go?
Where did those savages go?
We surrender!
Sir Blau!
They surrendered!
Step off my rock!
Wait, wait, wait!
I helped you out, man!
This man...
defended me from the bandits earlier.
Wait, but they threatened us earlier too!
That's right!
Yes, this is true!
I honor you...
from the old world.
You will take this...
as a sign of our offering in peace.
Hey, I appreciate that.
Where you stand is the Coldstone Fortress.
We are an ancient and old people.
How many people are you guys over here?
Help!
There's a polar bear!
Bear!
Help!
There are polar bears!
Wait, I thought you guys were joking!
Oh my god!
Do bears exist too?
The bear got you!
Oh!
Betrayers!
No!
I fucking knew it!
I should have taken the shot!
I fucking...
I knew it!
I knew I should have taken the shot!
I'm fucking going back to the pilgrim.
I should have killed them.
The bear curse!
They fucking struck again!
The bear curse was real!
I knew I should have taken the shot!
I got Bucky hitting the head in the back!
That would not protect...
Oh my god!
The fucking snow bears were real!
I fucking knew they were real!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe they were real all along!
I can't believe they were real!
Not again!
Oh my god!
I thought you guys were...
I was like, there's no way they were polar bears!
There's no way!
There were!
There were polar bears!
It always leads to the bears!
The polar bear...
It was a sign!
Oh my god, you see a bear...
It's like when you see it in the old times.
When you see...
When you see a crow...
It means you're gonna die soon.
When I see a bear...
I'm gonna die!
Every path...
Leads to the death...
From a bear!
Every single...
I'll never escape!
I'll never escape this fucking hell!
This is my...
Silent hill!
My silent hill...
Is I'll die to a fucking...
Anything related to a bear!
Ever since I accidentally...
I mercy killed that one guy...
I'm gonna go to the blood church...
And ask for help.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, I should've fucking...
Got a spawn point!
Oh!
Hello!
Hey!
I've died to a bear five times.
It's my way of life.
Every time I see a bear...
I knew death is coming.
Oh yeah, corn, that would be great sir.
Are you the corn man?
Thank you for this...
Corn, sir.
How's life doing for you...
In the wilds?
It's pretty bad.
I passed out.
And then I woke up dead.
Now I'm running back to my...
Dead...
Where I passed out.
Dead and...
Yeah.
Hopefully my home's not gone.
Wait, you don't live there?
Actually I got killed by a boar.
Oh you got killed by a boar, that sucks man.
I just met this guy.
Wait, is he friendly?
Is he friendly?
This guy's pretty cool.
Are you still home dude?
Sir?
Young sire?
Hermit in the woods?
Maybe he passed out too.
He might have.
He's literally just here.
Good luck in your journey to your body.
Hope you get all your stuff.
You too.
Thanks, this would be my fifth bear death.
But I hope so too.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna go to the church.
I don't think I want to interact with a guy named Crazy.
I don't want...
I'm not gonna interact with a guy whose name is literally Crazy.
Oh my god.
Please, I need to...
Maybe the church people would be nice.
Maybe.
Hey, there's a casino.
We'll gamble later.
When we stop dying.
I got betrayed.
By those men.
If I kept typing, I would have been dead.
Holy fuck.
If I kept typing, I would have died.
I can't believe it.
Here I go.
Always the bears.
Thank god I didn't.
I keep typing.
I looked to my left and I saw my lifeline.
The bear woman.
I lived.
Oh my god.
I actually lived.
I request...
I request shelter.
Oh.
What's that?
Okay, no, that's just paranoia.
You saw the bear and now you're scared.
You're next.
You saw the bear and now you're freaking out about every single thing you see now.
You're just freaking out because you saw the bear.
Oh, now they're not here?
Is there nobody here?
Oh my god.
They just disappeared.
There was an entire cult here and now they're gone?
Oh, that's freaky.
That's so freaky.
The entire cult just...
Disappeared.
Did they...
Was there a Kool-Aid scenario?
What?
Was it...
Was it Kool-Aid?
Don't drop your...
What happened?
They ascended.
Oh my god.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I agree.
I concur.
Did they all ascend?
The rapture happened.
The gates...
I missed.
Oh my god.
The gates welcomed them.
Okay, let's see.
We gotta...
Okay, we gotta go here.
Holy shit.
Can I...
Can I get...
I'm...
I'm slowly...
I'm slowly walking back.
I'm so far.
Back to the pilgrimage I go.
I feel like...
Why are they...
Why did they set up camps so far away?
What the fuck?
Why did they set it up so...
Oh my god.
There's no spawn that's here.
Keep an eye out for bears.
How do I get hemp?
What does hemp look like?
What does it even look like?
Oh, I don't wanna.
I'm so scared.
What if another bear comes over?
I can't.
I can't do this again.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
I can't.
I don't know if I can keep...
I don't know, guys.
What if...
What if another...
Wait.
Desperate times...
calls for desperate measures.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, that's good.
Guys...
Guys, I need to put... I need...
I need this shirt.
Okay.
No bears in sight.
We're safe for now.
Food is food!
Guys, I have one corn left in my name!
I have one...
I have one corn left!
Food is food!
And corn is not cannibalism.
It's not cannibalism if you don't think about it too hard.
There's no way I'd encounter another bear.
There's no fucking way.
I lived the first...
That was the very first bear encounter I ever...
I ever survived from.
So, like, I think...
I think it's over.
I think the curse is over.
It's over.
There's no way.
I literally...
I literally survived my very first bear encounter.
There's no way I could...
Now I survived my second bear encounter.
All I'm saying is I literally just survived my second bear encounter, chat.
Yeah, there's a coliseum.
Yeah.
I'm gonna grab this.
And now my third bear encounter.
Third bear encounter.
Now I survived...
And now I survived my third bear encounter.
Third time's the charm.
It's fine.
See, guys?
The curse is broken.
The curse is now officially broken, chat.
I think we did it.
There's no...
There's no way.
There's no more suffering.
We broke the...
We broke the curse.
Can you survive the...
Okay, yeah.
You know what?
I think I can, too.
I think I can.
I can't believe the church ascended.
And I laughed at them.
I didn't believe...
Maybe...
Who are the real gods?
Is it the blood god?
Or the old gods?
But...
The cult raptured.
They raptured.
I'm kidding.
The blood god.
Alright.
I feel like I'm still...
I feel like I'm like 20...
20 miles away.
Whoever protects me...
Whoever protects me from the fucking...
Whoever protects me from the...
God forsaken...
Bears will be my new god.
They will be my new god.
The moment I...
Survive bear encounters.
I will believe whatever you want me to believe.
There's loot here.
Oh, nice.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Let's go.
I have armor now.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking stacked.
It's over.
Oh wait.
You can't run with these.
Now I can swim.
I haven't met any wolves yet.
Thank fucking god.
They got the only thing I've encountered.
Which is stupid...
Fucking...
Bears.
Okay, nice.
We got scrap.
Oh, I got shorts.
Nice.
What is this?
Metal blade.
Oh, I can craft stuff.
Okay.
Alright.
We're almost here.
I almost thought I was gonna die from fall damage.
Oh, thank you for the...
Earthy boy.
Thank you for 10 gifted subs.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Alright.
I'm heading back.
Oh my god, I'm almost there.
I'm almost...
Back from my second...
I've lost count.
How many pilgrimages I've made now.
I've never any lost count.
But I'm back!
I'm back!
I have made my journey.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, that's shroud.
I recognize the shroud, boys.
Yeah, that's...
That's shroud.
Oh!
Okay.
What's going on?
I'm eavesdropping.
Okay.
I'm back from my pilgrimage.
Let's get out of here.
Let's leave them to their business.
Yeah, we...
Bye!
I'm back.
I've made the third pilgrimage.
They got us from behind!
I got...
Shaked from behind.
Do you have a sleeping bag?
I'm tired of traveling.
Did you live?
I made it back.
I made another pilgrimage.
I did it.
I saw four bears on my travel here.
Four fucking bears.
And I outran all four of them.
Wait.
Woah!
They shot!
No, I fucking ran like a bitch.
Get away from here!
Get away!
Just getting the wood.
Don't mind me.
Attack of what I have brought!
Just getting the wood.
Don't mind me.
I need a sleeping bag.
I can't.
I can't do another pilgrimage.
I cannot.
Wait, who's this guy?
Wait, how did he die?
That was when he got taken out earlier.
That's when we all died there.
The great war.
The great war of 2024.
I think we got ambushed or something.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
Please, I can't.
I can't do another pilgrimage.
I can't.
The great death.
This is like the emu war all over again.
I can't.
It's alright.
We need this.
We need...
Jackie to help us.
Oh.
I need a sleeping bag.
I can't make another pilgrimage.
I don't have it anymore in me.
If I die one more time and I spawn in 200 miles away.
Thank you sir.
Thank you for giving me the cloth.
Where's the cloth?
Where did I put the cloth?
I know.
This is my second time.
Can you hear me?
I know.
I killed four bears along the way.
I've been touched by the cloth.
With just a rock in my hand.
The devil's medal?
What does that look like?
Long dragon sticks.
People hold.
I don't think I've ever seen...
I don't think I've ever seen a devil's medal.
You see them holding lizards in their hands.
Lizards?
We build with wood and stone only.
No metal.
Wood and stone only.
What?
We range and should you kill someone.
You are only allowed to take one thing from them.
Wait, my gun is a key.
You take one thing and one thing only.
Wait, my gun...
My drop is a key.
You can't say that.
But what if I...
I will banish you from the lands of Everwinter.
Oh.
Yes.
I can tell you're a warrior.
Press tab, Doki.
Your hair is a beautiful shade of fire.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
I was touched by the bear claw.
And now I survive every bear encounter.
Alright, I'm in.
Do I have it?
I don't think I have it.
Where's my claw?
Grab the devil's medal.
Yeah, my AK is wood and stone.
Oh, there it is.
Hey, Gumi, Gumi.
Gumi here.
Oh my god, guys.
Guys.
They won't know, guys.
Guys, they won't know if I eat...
If I touch...
If I touch the lizard...
The gun.
They won't know.
My AK is made out of stone and wood.
Then why am I still here doing women's work?
Woah!
And what exactly is women's work?
What exactly is women's work?
Lady Gumiho, I assign you HR.
You will deal with any...
Acts of...
Chauvinism.
Sorry, we got HR?
We're progressive?
There's no crimes.
What did you mean by that?
We are vikings.
Yes, but there are women vikings.
And I'll give you a vikings funeral.
You draw your bow in our place of worship.
No, but we have to be progressive vikings.
Case in point.
There are shield maidens in the vikings.
What do you say of those?
You dare disrespect a shield maiden?
Vikings can't take a joke.
We must be having a sense of humor.
I thought we were a family.
Why would we take everything so serious?
Oh, sorry.
I forgot your...
I forgot...
I forgot the Nords...
That's the Nordics way of joking.
It's a little bit difficult to understand.
If you're under this rock, you are family.
We're all family here.
Those who are not building, come.
We go ranging.
Wait, I do not have a bow, sir.
Lady Gumi, with me.
I do not have a bow, sir.
Please, I can't make another...
This is my last straw.
If I die one more time, I'm not coming back.
I'm not...
I'm not coming back if I die one more time.
This area is too far.
This pilgrimage is too far.
I can't...
This was my last one in me.
We're hunting for cloth, guys.
We're hunting for cloth.
Yes.
I see it.
I feel like this is the gate to Valhalla.
This reminds me of the gates of Valhalla right here.
Come.
We're the shield maidens.
The lordship Sykkuno?
He's here?
Those are lizard guns.
But the lizard...
But our AK is made of stone and wood, so it's okay, right?
I will go up there with my rock.
I have not learned.
I've killed four of these.
I can kill a fifth.
Who are you?
I keep getting so close, and then I die to people.
Who killed you?
Did you kill him?
Just head north and you'll get there to the fortress.
Hello, brethren.
I've acquired cloth.
You have acquired cloth?
I shall craft us all beds.
Oh, thank you, Kaiser.
You shall be welcomed in Valhalla, Mason.
Oh my god, thank god I don't have to hunt.
I don't have to gather.
Thank god.
I don't have to do anything.
I'm coming over.
Oh my god, the sacred river.
We should do a viking funeral there one day.
You know women aren't allowed in Valhalla?
I don't think they know that yet.
The guardians of Valhalla.
Go away, pumpkin.
Oh, they are.
I thought they weren't.
Somebody was like, oh, they're not.
And I was like, what?
And I got confused.
Thank god they are.
Oh, women aren't allowed.
I got one guide.
Oh my god.
We're like the Valkyries.
Is there anyone there?
We can discover the land and claim it as our own.
Which way?
Which way is it?
Who said that?
I said that.
You're cooking.
A resort of sorts.
A resort?
A little vacation home for the vikings?
Full of fun.
Full of fun and no metal allowed.
Oh my god, this stream you have.
I don't know how to explain this, but I was told by an old god we would receive gifts if we don't partake in the dragon fire rods, guns.
We will receive a blessing.
What kind of blessing?
By old gods, I mean the faceless gods.
And by faceless, I mean face punch.
Who is he?
Wait, who's this?
Who goes there?
Norway!
Let's go, Norway!
Join us, join the free people.
I like how it's like we're talking in the old English and the chat box is like, yo, sup guys!
We shall create thy paradise.
Yo, guys!
Drop your clothes, drop your clothes!
Not the way of the viking.
Time travel, this is a time travel segment.
The bags are sleeping!
Oh my god, where is it?
Eat this, chatter.
Eat this.
Disperse the bags of sleeping.
Oh my god, I shall be reborn!
Once again!
How's it hanging, my...
Yes, we must go back to the fortress so we can be reborn.
How's it hanging, my fellow vikings?
In Valhalla, we go!
Anyway, women are allowed in Valhalla, so I don't think they know that yet, so we shall...
We've done it.
No, they won't know.
They won't know.
They're progressive.
They're progressive vikings.
In this Valhalla, we shall be accepted.
We're not allowed to have guns.
We're not allowed to have guns in this faction.
I think we should...
I don't know now.
Do you think they'll treat us...
Maybe we're the exception.
My gun is sort of made of stone and wood.
What did he say?
Yeah, but he was joking!
He was joking!
He said, don't you know about the viking joking?
Have you never talked to a Nordic?
That's how they joke!
That's how the Nords joke!
Those guys...
Yeah, those silly Scandinavians...
As a fellow Scand...
That's how I call myself.
That is how we joke.
This is how they joke all the time.
As a Scandinavian, I did not know this.
I must adjust my jokes.
Whoa, I hear things being broken.
Forgot how to do the sleeping bag.
The box?
Touch the box?
Oh, I touched the box!
The secret box!
Where do you put your sleeping bag?
Put it in team chat.
Put it in my team chat!
Can we come inside?
Okay,
what should we...
Bahala...
Did I spell it right?
Progressive...
I have a mouth that wants bed.
Welcome to the Cold Stone.
It's the Cold Stone.
This is the house.
This is our land.
Oh my goodness.
This is our fortress.
What kind of blessing shall the bountiful replenish?
What kind of blessing Our skin will now be fatter.
Our legs can become faster.
Our brains will crease the folds of reality.
Don't worry child.
If you stick to our ways.
We will show everyone that we are no one to be screwed with.
We'll never get killed by bears again?
They will become our friends?
If we believe?
I believe.
I believe now.
Guys, did you hear that?
I don't want...
You...
...are a place of worship.
Oh my goodness, I'm getting flashbacks.
What did you just call ColdStone?
What did you call ColdStone?
I'm sacred, lads.
He has an accent.
You are a guest under our roof.
He's a guy.
You are a guest here, and you disrespect our house of honor.
Please don't kill him.
Please, he's a good friend of mine.
I suffer a disease called rusty bones.
They're fragile.
If you shoot me once, I might just collapse.
Lord Shaki, I don't know if you're familiar, but he used to...
Don't ever...
Don't ever disrespect your house if you join.
Don't ever disrespect our home.
Sorry, this is ColdStone.
ColdStone, I love ColdStone.
Woo, ice cream!
Did he just compare Sacred Lance to ice cream?
I've given you a bed.
It's right here.
I am wearing an ice cream right now.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Lord Shaki.
Oh, wait, my sleeping bag's a race car!
Wait, it's a race car.
No, no, Sir John.
We do not kneel.
Get up on your feet!
You bow to no one.
Oh, sorry.
Bow to no one!
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
You're a clown!
All right, listen.
Look at how Lady Gumiho is dressed.
This is how we all must dress.
Billy Liza.
Yep, yep.
Listen, we cannot be wearing colorful clothing or reds or blues or greens.
No, we wear the old wooden armor.
But this shirt was passed down by my mother.
Can I request an exception?
Oh, what?
Sir Blau, I request an exception.
Sir Blau, are thou froggy boots okay?
Look at the drip.
Froggy boots are allowed!
What kind of a snail was that?
Huzzah!
Look at this little fella on my foot.
Huzzah to the froggy boots!
Oh my God, look at this little froggy!
How did you get the lizard to shape this way?
Yeah, how were you able to design that?
Huzzah!
How about you keep the lizard's face intact?
OOC.
Blau just goes OOC there.
Not gonna lie, they did look sick.
No, my beautiful blue shirt!
Does anybody have an extra bed I might be able to partake in?
Not gonna lie to that.
Maybe it'd be my friend, unfortunately.
They won't know.
I'm gonna get an AK and then I'll just be like...
I'll be made of stone and rock.
Sir Blau, I have procured a gift for you, my friend.
What the fuck, no!
What's going on outside?
Open the doors, open the gates!
Oh God, watch out!
Run!
It's gone!
Do not worry, you are safe now!
No tech, they have a lock.
That's not a lock!
It's a sacred...
It's a gift from our old gods.
Odin gave us that.
It's not a lock.
It's not technology if Odin gave it to us.
Press tab, open up your inventory.
It's a rune, exactly.
That is a sacred rune.
It's a warding rune, exactly.
What is this technology you speak of?
You are now one of us.
We are doing invites into the group.
Please go and see Lord Shaki, he'll get you in.
Lord Shaki!
Yes?
My AK will become a magic stick!
Brothers, Odin touched me and now I have a magic stick.
Odin came to me in a dream.
I need builders and raiders.
Builders, I need you to keep working on the Coldstone Fortress.
We must erect it.
How hard does the stone need to be?
What do the rangers do?
If you have a bow and you seek to range, come with me.
I don't have a bow, but I seek to range, sir.
I think you do have a bow, sir.
I would like an adventure.
Oh, thank you, thank you so much!
Now I have a bow.
No problem, milady.
Shaki, my beautiful wife, do you need food?
I have corn, it is okay, but I do need arrows.
I'm starving, I just realized that.
I need arrows.
Sirella, there's a mysterious man.
I don't know if he...
Where's the arrows?
I saw him lurking around and I didn't know what he was doing.
I will have to make you some.
Oh, thank you, I really appreciate it.
He smells musky.
I'm going to put some scrap away here.
I'm just going to put in the other...
Rope?
Let me check.
Nope.
I'm going to put all of this away.
I don't need any of this.
Yeah, I'm here!
Box.
I like how it's just called box.
On the right side, it should be like a quick craft and it should show an arrow.
You can just make like five of those or like ten.
Oh, nice!
Let's go, I can't wait to go hunting.
Hunting for the group.
I sure hope they haven't left us.
I think they left us.
It's okay, we'll explore on our own.
We can explore on our own.
They may be here.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Did you have the arrows?
Yeah, thank you.
That's enough arrows for me.
Eleven arrows is enough.
Oh!
Wait, wait.
Yes?
Our other brothers and sisters are this way.
Oh, more arrows.
Okay, nice.
They're over there.
What is that?
I've only heard of legends about it.
We should shoot it down!
Do you think the Old Gods would approve of that?
Yes, imagine how many families we'll feed.
The Old Gods wouldn't only approve.
They would require it.
It's like Indiana Jones 4.
It's like the newest Indiana Jones movie.
I'm sorry, I fell.
There was a... yeah, there was.
I think it was over me.
Oh wait, sorry, it was Indiana Jones 5.
I've lost track of...
It's kind of hard to do.
Here we are.
Rangers here!
Where are we going?
Yes!
Line it in!
What is that in Game of Thrones?
I've got peer pressure in my load.
They all shot, so I thought I shot.
I shot when I heard them shooting.
Wait, wait, don't do nothing.
Please, hold on.
What have you done?
Wait, dragon, we've met in another world, right?
Do we trust dragons?
It's the trash man!
The same dragon I know from before.
No, he's safe.
I know this dragon.
I know this dragon, guys.
I've fought with him before in many battles.
We're going to try this again!
Aiming at the metal rock!
Archers!
Knock!
Draw!
You son of a bitch!
I thought you were one of the leaders, Elam!
Elam, aren't you one of the leaders?
Hey, don't look at me.
I don't got a bow here, alright?
I think Elam...
We're ready.
We did it!
We won!
We learned!
Wait, who's that behind us?
Sabla, who's that?
Welcome, Harrison!
He has a metal lizard.
He has a metal lizard on his hip.
Wait, he does!
Metal lizard!
Metal lizard, real jerk!
I don't have any metal on me.
You have a metal lizard?
I can see it.
Elam, you're lagging hard.
Your mic is lagging.
You're bald!
Is he cutting in and out?
Oh, he does not sound normal for me.
That's true, that's true.
Wait, don't Vikings hate the British?
How is he a leader?
Oh,
there is a bear!
Are you okay?
I got you!
I took it out!
Are you okay, Shaki?
It's but a flesh wound!
You survived!
I don't even feel it.
I need meat.
I need some meat.
Do not worry, I removed the arrow in your head.
I performed a successful surgery.
I'm sorry, Lord Shaki!
Do I sound any different?
No, you sound great!
You sound just the same, Lord Shaki!
Just the same!
Nothing weird!
What's 2 plus 2, Shaki?
What's 2 plus 2?
I don't like avocados!
He has the green boots!
He has the green boots, Lord Shaki!
Take this.
It is the bone from my grandmother.
What is this?
Keep it close.
Never lose it.
Thank you so much, Shaki.
That is the token of our appreciation to you.
And our allegiance.
And here, this as well.
That is the arrow that slayed the dragon.
The metal dragon?
My grandfather.
I will cherish it.
Will you kill me?
I will keep it with my finest eunuch.
Wait, you're the dragon?
Don't kill him!
No, it wasn't me!
It wasn't me!
It was my great-great-great-great-grandfather!
If you spare one of your ancestors, they'll come back for revenge!
They'll come back for revenge if you don't kill the lion!
Kill him!
Traitor!
His name is Red!
His name is Red now!
I'm peaceful.
Honestly, I didn't think he would die that quick.
I'm going to be completely honest.
I didn't think he would...
His machete really does pack a punch.
Oh, this is perfect.
We actually need skulls.
Oh, you need skulls?
You guys seem friendly.
We need skulls.
This is perfect.
Here is a skull for you.
Oh, thank you.
Was that his skull?
No, it was abandoned.
I've slain long ages ago.
But I shall give it to you as a peace offering.
I've never heard that before.
Thank you.
Thank you for the skull.
The king does have a beautiful voice.
We leave the cursed walls and false king with me!
We will keep this peace with you, sir.
I want to see the blaze.
No, no, no, no, no.
We're not ready.
We're not ready for a fucking door, man.
Okay, alright.
A door, let's go!
Yay!
Yes!
This is exactly what we wanted.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
A big capsule is actually being shipped right now.
It's not quite here, but...
How many people did it take to make this castle?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Wait!
A tour!
Welcome to our home!
Thank you, yes.
Our humble abode.
Oh my, how many years...
How many years did it take you to build this?
Generations?
Your great-great-father made this castle?
Yes.
And it's still not complete?
Listen, I know you guys...
I know you guys don't kneel to anyone.
I'm just saying...
If you consider kneeling, some of this could be yours.
We do not kneel.
Guys, I sort of want to kneel.
Guys, I sort of...
Yes!
Oh, let's go, let's go!
We must feed!
Are you sure you do not wish to join us?
We can be hired by Mercy.
We are brothers.
Nothing more, nothing less.
I brought a skull!
Once.
But I've given you a skull!
Does that not count?
Oh,
a bonus skull.
Okay.
It's the metal dragon!
It's the dragon!
The dragon's here!
Leave!
Run from the dragon!
Run!
Quick, back to the fortress!
Do not run!
Does that mean...
Does that mean we shoot on sight?
Anybody that we don't know?
No.
Don't talk about my mother like that!
No way...
We'll never know what LM is saying.
We'll never know!
Guys, how do I emote?
It's Taki!
A boar!
Nice!
We shall feed the families with this!
Drink some mead and you shall feel better!
Drink some lead?
Mead!
I said mead!
I mean, you can drink lead if you want!
I see someone on the bridge, sir!
Sir, that's a skull!
We must go talk to them!
That could be a skull!
We must draw them in!
Before...
We must be one of them!
Wait, that's two!
We don't pretend to be traitors, we are traitors!
Wait, stop!
Everybody stop!
We will be traitors first!
We will be trading cloth and other objects!
And then, when I say the signal...
We fire!
Hello!
We are traitors!
What's the signal?
I think...
Before they figured it out...
No, stop!
Holy shit!
I could tell they were onto us.
They were onto us, I could sense it.
I can't!
Oh my god!
That was so...
That was so good!
Oh my god!
I can't!
I feel bad.
We need it.
We need the skulls to become allegiance with the kingdom.
I can't, guys.
I can't.
That was so good.
You must answer the riddle.
She can't sing.
I'll do it all for the nookie.
Grab the skull!
Another skull!
I can't!
Oh my god!
I need it!
I can't!
Hi!
Oh my god!
I can't!
I have tears!
I have tears in my eyes!
I can't!
Give me a sec!
I need...
I need to reset myself!
I can't!
This is...
I'm coming over!
I need...
I can't!
Holy fuck!
I'm getting my cough drops!
I can't!
This is...
Oh my god!
I lost my dignity!
I'm naked!
I joined...
You guys wanted me to join the blood god?
I can't!
I fucking can't!
Take this.
This potato.
I love vikings.
You're rejecting his offering?
You are rejecting his kind offering?
I'm eating the potato.
This is what you must eat to join our brotherhood.
Indeed.
Our diet is only potatoes and corn.
You must eat.
I'm eating the leaves of the seed.
Yes.
The gods bless you.
I still...
I can't!
I'm still thinking about that first kill.
I'm still thinking about the traitor kill.
I can't.
That is the signal.
Oh my god.
There is no blood god.
We shall not anger him.
It's not even a real god.
Wait, are we still traitors?
Hello!
We're here to trade.
Do you have anything?
Do you smell the air?
What do you smell?
I have a hat.
I smell something.
I smell fear.
We shall let him pass for now.
How are you going to say we need horses and then you let the only horseman we've seen thus far leave?
That does not seem logical.
Why must we give him mercy, Blau?
Oh my god.
What is this?
An iron dragon?
Some kind of land serpent?
It's a dead... Oh my... I think it is dead.
Boy!
Yes.
I know those blue shirts might be important to you, but you must remove them.
We must all look like a bunch of savages.
Yes, good!
Look at how Lady Gumiho is dressed.
This is how we should look.
I apologize.
It was...
No, my blue shirt!
My blue shirt!
It was the first clothing I've ever owned.
Goodbye, blue shirt!
Goodbye!
I accepted the win.
There's no H&M in Valhalla.
There's sadly no H&M.
Yes, what is it?
What is the word, Gumi?
Are vikings allowed to gamble?
Is gambling a sin in Valhalla?
No gambling?
A hat?
Oh my...
It's okay, I dropped some corn.
Oh my god, look at me.
I dropped some corn seeds.
We don't need them.
We have so much corn.
The bouncer of Valhalla doesn't like that shirt.
Loot on the way!
How many skulls do we need to get?
Did we not kill three?
I thought we killed three.
Someone must have an extra skull.
I remember killing three.
Get him out!
Harvest him.
Get the skull!
The bones.
Do we have a skull, Gumi?
They have no brain?
Oh, I have a skull!
I have a skull!
There's a body!
Harvest!
Wait, he has items!
What is that?
Is that?
He has a steed!
Sir LM has a steed!
Him and his car!
What do we not need?
What am I meant to do now?
I dropped skull on the floor!
There's a lot of them around us.
Bear!
Oh my god, thank god.
I got it!
Harvest the bear!
Oh my goodness, ow!
I'm bleeding.
We need one more skull!
Wait, how many skulls do we have now?
Yeah, someone has a skull.
Who has a skull?
That should be five.
Should it not?
Oh, you're out of inventory space.
Oh, a rock.
Just for me?
One last...
Sir Blau, I have an idea.
We could sacrifice...
Wait!
Shoot him!
All I'm saying is that we could send...
We could send one person to Valhalla.
We can send one man to Valhalla.
We could sacrifice one person to Valhalla.
I could not.
It's not stolen.
That's why I want you to ride it.
I want your name on this horse.
I will name this horse Stormrider.
It was owned by Mendo.
He won't mind.
I know not who this knight is.
We're on a mission.
Oh my god.
Fucking Elem's voice just cutting in and out.
It's just cutting in and out there.
We just need one more.
Wait, is that a church over there?
It is a church.
Aren't there people in churches?
Wouldn't there be people in churches?
Don't we raid churches as Vikings, sir?
No.
Don't we pillage and raid?
And take their women?
And children?
Those are the East Vikings.
We're the West.
You're having a meeting, sir.
We are the West.
Amen.
Yeah!
I'm being baptized.
Don't tell anybody.
I think it's a fucking cult.
I think it's a cult.
I don't know how to get out.
Don't tell them.
I think it's a cult and I'm stuck.
It's a cult.
Would you like to join us to speak the cult?
Oh, it's in my eye!
Oh, no!
Run!
I can't see!
We got it in my eye!
We got it in my eyes!
I think that's an orangey right there, Goomy.
I think you're having an orangey.
I know.
I saw some white stuff earlier.
That was crazy.
It's like a lot of skulls to me.
Take the horses.
They have a metal horse.
Where is it?
Hello.
Hello, my children.
There's a horse.
I'm going over.
I'm taking their horse.
Wait, that's our horse?
Oh, okay.
We need one more skull and we need to take the skulls and the horses back.
Who will be a sacrifice for a skull?
You will go to Valhalla if you sacrifice yourself.
The gods will recognize you.
I need a brave sacrifice.
Someone here, stand before me.
We will find somebody.
We should not kill one of our own.
Okay, fine.
We'll find someone.
You're right.
That's crazy.
Why would we kill one of our own?
I'm just saying Valhalla sounds mighty cool.
I'm saying Valhalla sounds mighty tempting.
I think a leader would offer himself, no?
We don't actually have a leader.
We're leaderless.
By the way, guys, we vote on the leader for the day at noon PST tomorrow because we're a democracy.
Whoa, wait!
Sir Blau, there's so many people up ahead!
They do not wear clothes.
Hello!
Oh, shit!
Hey, Gibby!
Hey!
Hello!
Hello, what's good, bro?
Democratic Vikings!
What's up, bro?
It's the mandem, ain't it, bro?
To the time traveling again.
Thank you, thank you, I love you.
What's going on, boys?
I'm on my ride right now.
What is this iron contraption?
I can't see your name.
Where are you?
It's on my bike!
Yeah, the time traveling.
What is this metal contraption?
What's up, yo?
I did it.
I don't want to take those from you.
That's awkward.
Hello!
Hello?
Oh, you're here again!
Long time no talk!
I think I need to take matters to my own hands.
I need to take matters to my own hands.
What if I find a man right now?
We're the Vikings!
Like a person's skull?
Take my skull, Elm.
I have a map for you.
Open up my map.
We have procured a scar!
What the fuck's wrong with you?
He sacrificed himself for Valhalla!
Don't worry, he shall be welcomed into the gates of Valhalla.
Shall we return home?
Wait, when did I join that?
I don't want to be a peacekeeper.
I think it's if you just don't kill anybody for a while.
Check out this one.
We must return!
We shall return!
My brain does not handle it.
Your technology confused me.
Elm, Elm, why is your name red, Elm?
My eyes are more crossed.
Hahaha!
We shall return home.
Return home to the fortress.
I missed the killing, guys.
I miss it.
We became too weak.
Hikumi, I miss the killings.
Oh!
They're on the metal steed!
How did you get the metal steed?
We have tamed the beast!
You've tamed the beast?
The beast has been tamed.
Oh my god, the metal serpent!
We have tamed the beast, my friends.
Oh!
Behind!
Inside!
It's you behind!
It's the apocalypse!
It's the world eater!
It's Ragnarok.
I believe that was Ragnarok that we just saw.
So that we can become allies.
They're king.
The great world serpent.
I knew God of War would be handy today.
I don't know if anybody's pointed it out, but every time you take a step, Elim, you squeak.
Yeah.
It's so bad.
He was on the metal steed!
The metal beast!
He was on Ragnarok!
He was riding Ragnarok!
If you will deliver the skull, you must take a steed!
I believe the men of my kin is building already.
Sir foolish.
Here is your horse.
Elim, shut your mouth up.
I'm sorry.
I don't see it through my window.
I'm sad that next week I'll be...
I'm sad next week I'll be...
I have to...
I have to leave Canada next week.
I wish I could play more.
The first couple of...
Oh... we are we lagging again?
Oh no, is it the server?
Okay, wait.
No, everybody is moving.
Okay, I need water.
Where's the water?
Okay, we gotta go to the lake.
I'm dehydrated.
Dehydrated right now.
Is there water nearby?
There are quite slow.
Yeah.
We gotta go to the fortress anyway.
I'm just gonna run straight to the fortress.
Let's see...
I need to head to...
I need to head to the ri... It's okay.
I got food too.
Pumpkin?
Can pumpkin rehydrate me?
Oh, it can!
Nice!
That's what fruit does.
So much stuff.
Oh my god, I have so much money for gambling.
Cause I've looted so many people.
Oh wait, no.
I threw away my scrap.
God damn it!
I threw away all my scrap!
No!
I threw away... I wanna use the bathroom too.
I gotta head back to the fortress.
I gotta... I need it.
Wait, where am I?
I'm over here.
I need to head to the fortress so I can use the bathroom and be safe.
Yeah!
Wait, what happened to your cock?
What happened to your...
Hello!
Hello there!
Squatty Toby!
I'm now going to try hiring...
You know...
We got LM's sicking VC.
I don't know how to fix his VC!
What's your request?
Oh, what are you doing?
Oh, it's...
If you see one of the...
I need to go and collect stuff.
Oh, yeah.
But in where?
Is it...
It is...
There's a big fork.
There's a lot of us.
I wish...
Come visit...
Really?
Oh, maybe I will.
That's so far.
I could've done it.
It was very tempting.
How do I fix LM's VC and stuff?
Wow!
Oh, no.
There's a scientist.
How do I heal?
I don't have heals.
I'm bleeding.
Oh!
Oh, I might die!
LM, do you have meds?
I'm gonna die!
LM, do you have bandages?
The floor is down.
The floor.
Do you have bandages?
Here, take this.
Take this.
I need bandages.
Thank you.
Oh, my god.
Okay, I've ended up throwing.
Get your veggies!
I shall eat my veggies.
Thank you.
Thank you for defending me.
Toki's mortal enemy pig.
What the hell?
Did LM not hear me?
I was like, LM!
Did it fucking heal me?
Okay.
Might as well just eat some pumpkins and heal up.
I gotta eat my veggies.
I was like, LM!
LM!
Do you think they have...
Wait.
They disappeared.
Gumi and them disappeared from the map.
Where did they go?
Wait.
They're too far.
Did they disappear from the...
Oh, wait.
No.
Did they...
Oh, no.
They're over there.
They rode back.
LM is so locked in.
I don't know how I got into this.
I don't know how I suddenly managed to...
From a blood cult to Vikings.
It truly is.
Rust is a beautiful thing.
Just rust things.
Yeah.
Hope you can find...
Hope you can find a bike.
You mean those metal...
The metal horses?
No.
Technology is...
Valhalla does not welcome metal horses.
Viking is pure honor and fight.
It's all about being welcomed in Valhalla, guys.
Metal steeds are prohibited.
Unless it's Ragnarok.
Thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
Sir Jett.
There's a gambling leaderboard now, too?
What the fuck?
Wait.
Why are we going this way?
We're supposed to go this way.
I need to use the bathroom.
I need to head straight to the fortress and fucking deposit all of this.
I need to...
I need to use the bathroom and deposit all of this.
Yeah.
I'm heading back.
Boomi and Blau are going to donate the skulls.
I will not die to a bear.
To a weak fucking bear.
I have been blessed by the gods.
Is that our home?
Hello?
The bike gang?
They're trying...
They're trying to get human skulls.
They pulled up on me and him while we were here.
And they asked us for our skulls.
It was Winnie and Coconut.
It's them!
Them!
So they let me go.
But they are now chasing Lord Blau down the street with Gummi.
Gummi, yeah.
Wait, you must tell Shaki.
You must tell Shaki what you heard.
He's behind you.
Shaki!
There is a gang that's trying to kill us.
There's a bike gang.
They're trying to collect human skulls.
Specifically Viking human skulls.
Oh no.
They are bike gang.
They were circling around here in a mad...
In their metal steeds.
And they...
Yeah, metal steeds.
We must tell Blau about this.
They're chasing him right now.
I'm pretty sure he's chasing...
Sir Blau perished.
They got him?
Did they take our skulls?
The...
No!
We must prepare.
Did they get you too?
I'm now naked.
They got him too!
Wait, what was the code?
I do not know the rune code!
No, I do not.
I didn't bring the cloth with me.
I've been looking for cloth as well.
What is the rune code?
What is the code to get in?
Oh, here.
It is...
The old gods.
Oh, okay, yeah.
What is it?
Got it.
Let it be known.
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll put away my materials.
How do I equip arrows?
It is the old gods.
That's the old gods?
That's the old god number?
That's not a god.
Oh my gosh.
Look at what I found!
This metal thing.
What is it?
That's disgusting.
It's like a picture.
But like, forever.
How do I equip the arrows which I have crafted?
I broke him, I made him OOC.
That picture went forever.
I can't believe you went OOC.
That fucking cracks you.
That fucking breaks your character.
How do I equip arrows?
Is this bow not what I think it is?
I see.
Got it, got it, got it.
It's like throwing a spear, I see.
So shaky.
I have contraband.
What kind?
I don't know what to do with this.
Well, what you do is you take it and you put it in the box we were just next to.
That's all you need to do.
The one down there that's out in the open?
Yes, exactly.
We're protected by our doors.
Okay.
What is that sound?
It's a beast.
Sounds like a metal beast.
Watch out.
I'm prepared to take it.
If you have more than two clothing items on, then it will shoot you.
And then it will rocket everything and then we'll all die.
So make sure...
Oh, okay.
I will not, I will not, nope.
I will not be fighting the metal monster.
I have changed my mind.
Yep.
Is there a bed by any chance?
Do you have cloth?
I have 10.
I have 40.
No, I have leather.
Shoot.
I'm back.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
I needed to get water too.
Hi.
I didn't realize.
I didn't know what Jackie sounded like outside of role playing.
This is my first time.
This is my first time meeting, like bump, meeting him in rest.
And then like the fact that his voice changed entirely after I fucking broke.
I broke him out of role play.
From like fucking fucking Nordic Viking accent to like fucking gamer bro.
I was not, I was not expecting that.
I didn't realize that they sounded like that.
I was like...
I was just like holy fuck.
Oh my God.
They'll close the doors.
They'll be fine.
There's people there.
I want to see if they're...
Oh, wait.
They're coming back.
There's people there.
I did not expect that to be his real voice.
Like I legitimately was like so surprised.
Have any of you guys got the drops yet?
You guys got the AK drop?
I'll just be like Odin came to me in a dream.
He gave me this magic stick.
And then maybe they'll let me.
That's like plus one RP right there.
No, I'm good.
I have a sleeping bag already inside.
Oh, did you manage to deliver the skulls?
Where did...
Where did the metal steed gang go?
They're across the bridge?
Oh, that's dangerous.
Alright.
That's good that you guys got it.
Wait.
That code doesn't work?
Must be in the back only then.
The front code doesn't work.
Hey!
How was it?
How was delivering the skulls?
What was the deal?
Oh, so you guys had to hunt again?
You guys had to hunt again?
Wait.
We need a stable to house our horses.
Who shall take this task?
I can do it, my lord.
I got this, my lord.
I'm happy to.
Sir, Demo.
Yes.
I now grant you the title of stable master.
Thank you.
Yes.
Oh, wow.
Build us a stable fit for our ranging horses.
Let's find a spot for this.
Oh, my God.
The stable master.
He shall take care of the horses, right?
What shall I do with this?
It should be next to the towers.
Right here, sir.
I love the horses.
Do you know how to build like a trough?
And like, you know, all the stuff that...
Build it right here.
Yeah.
Right here?
Perfect.
I will get to work right away, my lord.
I won't let you down.
Sir, Demo.
Make it aesthetic.
Yeah.
What happens if he doesn't make it aesthetic?
I'm just wondering.
You gotta have like some motivation.
Some motivation to build a nice stable.
You don't wanna half-ass it.
Alright.
I wanna...
High five with this title.
Well, but...
Yeah, but the stable is much more important.
Yes.
A metal frog?
What is that?
I also need some cloth.
Why is he...
He's a biker gang?
Do we take him out?
He's in our territory.
What do we do with him, Blau?
He's a pargarian.
We need to have a truce with him.
What were the tales of the biker gang?
Where did they go?
They left.
I don't know.
Someone else came and drove them out.
We need revenge on them.
Where do they live?
I need...
Wait, you did?
I don't know.
I'm sorry, you're right.
I need one human skull though.
My kings gave me a mission.
I need one human skull.
You bet not for the free people.
I've made trades with Dimoke.
He vouches for me.
I might have sold him a skull, guys.
I might have sold him one skull.
Rangers!
I assign Rangers, Jackie, Dragon, and Elum.
Go out with Sir Wicked.
Get a skull.
What will you give us in return?
What do you need?
Oh, Lady Doki, you go with them as well.
We need a skull.
We need 50 pumpkin seeds.
What do you need?
I'm sorry?
We need to get a skull.
We need cloth.
Do you have any cloth?
We need lots of cloth.
I don't have more cloth.
Oh.
Rangers, go out with Sir Wicked.
I can feed you.
I'll stay here at the cold stone.
This will feed your family for generations.
You guys don't like pumpkin?
Oh, okay.
We eat meat.
We know we love pumpkins, right guys?
Wait.
Meat?
I don't really.
I don't really like pumpkin, to be honest.
We don't eat our veggies.
We're Vikings.
How about some corn?
Do you want some corn?
Oh, you're corn people.
Corn and meat.
That's all we eat here.
What a lovely diet.
Corn and meat.
We must find a skull.
Onwards go for you.
This is a quest for you.
We've hired a hit squad now.
It's time.
It's time to go and find people.
We are on a new mission.
We're on a new mission now.
We must travel the bridge if we want to find skulls.
How did I become the leader?
Bro, I feel like we're like mercenaries now.
How do we lure them in?
What's our way of trying to lure them in before they just run away?
Maybe we put our bows away.
Yeah, we put our bows away and say we're here to trade.
I'll bring a corn out.
We pretend, yes.
We pretend to be traders.
We pretend to be...
Shaki, what is our code again?
What is our signal?
What is our signal, Shaki?
You're gonna die right now!
That's a good one.
That was a great signal.
They'll never see it coming.
They'll never know.
How would they know?
How would they fucking know?
Wait, Squire John is already asleep?
No.
Oh, the Lurklings, this is...
Honestly, we've been doing fantastic.
We've grown by numbers.
Pretty quickly.
On the third day, we shall be blessed.
I came here with two people and now your tribe is huge.
We have grown.
You did come at a time when everybody had left.
Wait, bear?
I need cloth.
How many arrows do I have?
Oh, I have 34.
Yeah, we have...
Wait, he is guarding a package!
A body!
He's guarding a body!
Skull!
The bear has given!
Get your cloth!
Oh my, he has a key!
Yes, way to go, guys.
Way to go.
I told you, we cross the bridge and we find the skull.
You're so wise.
Thank you, Lurklings.
Blessed be the Lurklings.
What?
I'm so sorry.
Sorry?
I tapped out my brain.
Elom has neurodegeneration.
We had to perform a surgery on his head.
It's okay.
I'm British.
I just get crazy with knives.
I'm sorry.
Yes, we took him from his home and raised him.
But he still has the British in him.
I'm sorry.
It's not fixable.
Did you guys take my stuff?
Wait, that was you?
I got killed by the bear.
Yeah, we found your body, but it was already...
It was already, like, dead.
Like, we found your backpack.
That's...
We'll find the murderer.
We'll find the person who vultured your stuff.
Sorry.
Consolation prize.
That was awkward.
Here, here.
The animal that took your life.
I can't drop anything.
Here you go.
I found this.
I can't drop anything.
You can take this.
Here, have my shorts.
You deserve them.
If I...
Hold on.
Just any minute now.
We can...
Just any...
Hold on.
Come up here.
Oh, it's because we're on the bridge.
Yes.
Here, here.
I found this.
You can take this.
Wait, why can't I throw stuff?
Oh, and this doesn't fit my style, so you should have this too.
Here, join a band.
Join a band?
You look better than you probably did before, I'll be honest.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know what you had on before, but this is definitely better.
Do you wish to join the Lurklings?
You bow to renounce all gods and kings.
He's always...
Except for the old and new gods.
I thought...
Yeah, I thought he was already in the Lurklings.
He's been building stuff for us, Blau.
Oh, is he?
Oh.
That's a little awkward.
Bro, this guy Blau already hit me, so I'm running as fast as I can to get away from him.
What's he doing in...
What is he doing in Lurkling territory?
Sir Blau, sir Blau, sir Blau, sorry, sorry, my sire, sorry, sorry, sorry.
He's kneeling, he's kneeling!
We do not kneel.
Oh, no kneeling?
Oh, sorry, no kneeling.
Sorry, I'll take it back, I'll take it back, I'm so sorry.
They don't kneel.
We don't do anything but wood and stuff, and they don't kneel to anyone.
They renounce all gods and kings.
Oh, okay.
I don't know your preferences, but I do not do wood.
Blau, I wish to propose something.
No, not food, woods.
Oh my god, they're gonna get married.
Take this.
Thank you.
Hey, what did I miss?
We got the skull, we did our mission.
Well, um...
I know.
Well, did you guys, uh...
I'll see if you can...
I'm going this way.
What's your mission?
Oh, he ran off into the woods.
He ran off, yeah.
I'm going to meet my friends.
Oh!
Foxbox and others.
Do you think, do you think they have metal lizards now?
They don't do that kind of...
They don't?
What are they, what are they part of?
I think they're part of the new world.
The new world?
What's the new world?
Are you abandoning us?
No.
She has friends at the new world.
I'm making alliances for us.
We must go with her.
Protection.
We must protect our own.
They found land across the ocean?
Standing for Rapidash 15.
What are these magic words you're saying?
She's speaking in tongues.
Skip to the toilet, riz, riz, ya, w's.
Is this the new world language you're speaking of, Gooby?
Aye, dokey.
Ragnarok taught me it.
Ragnarok stands for Rizzler.
What does the A stand for?
Oh, I know what G stands for.
I wonder what the G stands for.
Gamer goo.
That's
a surname, man.
Wait, where are they on the map?
You know, like Gyatabayo.
Gyatabayo?
Did you literally just say Gyatabayo?
Lily!
I would recommend you should not follow us.
We're going on a really long run.
Wait, where is it on the map?
Where is it on the map?
Oh my, okay, let's go.
Okay, okay, yeah.
Yeah.
It's all about Valhalla!
But on the third day, they say...
I don't even know what I'm known as anymore.
Another pilgrimage.
You became the leader of the rangers?
Oh my god, I don't know.
I can't believe I'm doing another pilgrimage.
I thought this was over.
I thought... I thought these ways are behind me.
Maybe we can find a metal seed.
They'll never know.
They'll never know if we...
They'll never know if we took one of them.
How would they know?
Odin will never know.
Oh my god, we can say... No, no, no, we'll say that...
Oh bear, oh shit!
I'm sorry!
I'm panicked, I'm panicked!
No, I'm sorry!
No, I forgot to...
Where am I?
Okay, I forgot to sleep in the sleeping bag.
Did I not?
Oh, I'll just make you a bag.
Just wait.
I'm gonna go drown.
Be in the water.
Let me drown!
Let me drown in the water.
First F1 in time.
Okay, I need to know if it doesn't show my console.
I need to know if it doesn't...
Oh my god.
Okay, slash kill.
Wait, how do I...
This is slash kill?
What was the kill command?
What is it?
There's no kill.
Okay.
Oh my god.
You hurt me!
Odin hurt me!
Oh my god!
I can't even have to wait to 100!
I'm just progressive.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Here I go.
Odin hurt me.
Sorry.
I shall never have these thoughts again, Odin.
I shall never have these thoughts again.
Hello.
The all-seeing father, Odin.
He hurt...
I got killed by a bear again!
He got me!
It's almost like the bear curse...
The bear curse has hit me yet again!
Yes, I shall respawn.
I shall die here.
Alright, I'll wait.
I'm just gonna wait.
I don't wanna travel.
I'll just get a heart attack.
The curse never left!
I had some impure thoughts.
The impure...
I'm sorry.
I shall never have those thoughts again.
I shall never think of such...
heinous thoughts in my head.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Dude, we're fine.
We're fine.
We'll just wait.
I can wait.
That's why you never...
Never betray Odin.
Oh my god.
I'm so...
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired from...
I'm so tired from the fucking bears.
The fucking bears!
They'll never leave me alone.
I let my guard down.
I let my...
Guard down.
For like 5 seconds.
Like the one time...
The one time I finally let my guard down.
They came back.
No,
I'm waiting.
I have 95 seconds left.
95 seconds till I can come back.
They were waiting for this very moment.
They give the 100 minis pass.
No!
I was promised that the bears will be friendly.
I was promised by Valhalla that they would be friendly and they'll be my friend.
What happened?
Is it because of my impure thoughts?
Chat?
Is it because of my thoughts?
It was just one little thought.
What?
The impure thoughts tainted thee.
Yes, you were punished.
I was punished for the...
I'll never think about the metal horses again.
I swear.
But it's somebody just happened.
It's somebody just happened to like, gave me it.
Like, I wouldn't say no.
I just won't actively search for it if it just happens to come to me.
In a dream.
Then like, is that truly...
Is it truly blasphemy at that point?
Is it...
Is it?
Is it really blasphemy if it just showed up in my inventory?
A gift shouldn't be a problem.
Yeah!
I am back.
Okay, where's my stuff?
Where'd my stuff go?
Gumi!
Where's my stuff?
Where is it?
Thank you.
It's because we talked about the metal steed, Gumi.
We talked about the metal steed and we got punished.
We got punished for it.
No, I heard you.
You said it too.
You were thinking about it too.
Don't lie to me.
You were thinking about it.
Odin will punish you.
Because I was thinking it loud.
It's because I was thinking it louder.
I was thinking it louder.
Anyway, as I was saying...
As I was saying...
If a bear...
Sorry, not bear.
No more bears, please.
But...
I was saying...
If...
We walked over and...
We happened...
Oh, it's a scientist.
Okay.
I was saying like...
Oh!
Hello?
Hello, everybody.
Hey!
I just... I'm a tourist here.
I'm just a little tourist.
See?
I'm here sightseeing.
Birdwatching.
I was finding a blue-crested sparrow.
Friend?
It was no friend.
It was just me.
I'm just birdwatching.
I saw a blue-crested sparrow.
I saw a blue-crested sparrow in the trees and I was just following the path.
I'm just a...
There was a...
There was a... No!
I followed a blue-crested sparrow right here.
Why would I have binoculars?
I was birdwatching right here.
Okay.
What do we got over here?
Who are you?
Oh!
Okay, okay.
I'm here.
I have...
I have scrapped you.
You can gamble.
That's unnecessary.
You can gamble at the casino.
They gave us a skull.
Oh, they did it?
Alright.
They gave us a skull.
There's a hole in the poop though.
I ain't gonna lie to you.
Oh my god.
Poop on the poop.
I'm in school all over again.
This is way too much.
I just...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My skull saved us.
Oh my god, my skull.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
We ran into the scientist.
Oh my god.
All I'm saying is that the bear saved us.
It was a sign from Odin.
He needed me to die to save us.
It was a blessing.
It was a blessing in disguise.
We need to harvest the skull.
We need to harvest the skull in case we bumped into...
We need to...
Oh fuck!
Okay.
How do I do team chat?
What do I press?
Oh.
They...
They threatened us.
I was...
I was so scared.
I was just trying to burn.
Oh my god.
Where did Goomy go?
Goomy, where did you go?
Oh, there she is.
Oh my god.
She found a horse!
Oh my god, I got hazed.
Goomy, why are you just sitting there?
We should have killed...
We should have killed them when we had the chance.
Why did we give mercy?
Wait, is that your friend?
Is he here?
No, there's nobody here.
Do you live here by yourself?
No, I'm just exploring.
Oh, you're an explorer!
You're a tourist!
Do you not belong?
You better look out for the metal dragons.
Yeah, the metal dragon gang.
They're scared.
They make you pick up shit.
The metal dragons.
Yeah, they ride these metal dragons and they surround you.
And then it's like you're in high school all over again.
They're gonna stuff you in a locker if you're not careful.
When you hear the sound!
The metal dragon!
Run!
Wait!
Goomy!
We could have taken his skull.
You think we should kill him?
You're on a horse.
I know, but I'm not running on it.
P.A.C.E.
It's okay, next time.
Next time.
We need a skull!
For insurance.
For our safety.
We can't...
I'm scouting ahead.
Wait, who's that?
Who's that?
Wait, how did you get here?
What happened to you?
Again?
You gotta get a skull for insurance.
But you have nothing on you, right?
So, like, you dying will be...
Remember Valhalla.
You need to do a sacrifice yourself.
Do it for Valhalla!
For Valhalla!
Okay.
We gotta get the skull.
You harvest.
Yeah, you harvest.
He has nothing on him.
I'll get the scrap, so if they come back, we can donate the scrap.
Okay, alright, we're fine.
Alright, we have insurance.
We have insurance now.
Alright.
If they come back...
Yeah.
I got it.
Odin will be proud of his sacrifice.
No!
Are you okay?
Guys, you don't understand.
We need the skull.
We don't wanna get bullied.
We don't wanna get cyber bullied again.
It's a sacrifice.
His sacrifice will ensure our survival.
His sacrifice...
That's good, that's good.
Where's your friend?
We need the lunch money.
They took our...
The thing is, we need to...
We need to bully somebody else to take their lunch money so the bigger bullies won't kill us and stuff us in lockers by us giving their lunch money.
It's a cycle.
Yeah.
We just need to make sure we have lunch money on us.
The pyramid scheme of bullying.
Oh my god!
It's the other way around?
Where even are we?
Yeah?
See what?
We're so...
We're so far away from R15.
Find me another horse, Gumi!
Gumi, find me a horse!
Oh, it's you again.
Hey!
We don't need your skull anymore.
We found a skull.
Oh no, we have a skull.
Look, show her the skull.
Yeah, we got a skull.
Yeah, to sacrifice themselves for us.
Give them a skull and you'll be fine.
Yeah, like that one.
Your horse just pooped by the way when you said that.
Yeah.
Is there a horse?
Is there a horse anywhere for us?
We need another horse.
So we can both ride the horse at the same time.
No, don't say that.
No, no, that's a different thing you're thinking about.
Gumi, that is an absolutely different thing that could be real.
Gumi.
Don't say that.
It could be real.
Oh my god.
Where is another horse?
How is there a lack of horses?
How is there a lack of horses in this world?
I'll just take that to that room.
I feel like everybody has like...
ransacked all the horses.
It's so...R15 is so far away.
Everybody has ransacked the horses.
They've stolen all the horses.
Do you think like somebody...
Maybe if we go to a village, we can steal a horse there.
I'm okay.
Oh, I'm okay.
She's chasing you.
He's chasing you.
Just in case.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We're okay.
No, no, no.
The bear chased after Gumi and not me.
The bear chased after her.
I'm safe.
I'm okay.
Yeah, it was chasing after you, but...
It was chasing you and not me.
Okay.
Two squares?
Oh my god!
We're almost there!
We're
almost there!
Um...
No, I don't.
Now we have scrap.
And cloth.
I mean, there's trees ahead of us.
We can just farm the wood from there.
Use a rock.
You don't got no rock?
Yeah, but when you're harvesting, you might as well grab a rock in case.
Like, you know when you're...
It's like a desperate measure.
If they're too close to you, just bring up the rock.
And just like, you know...
Oh.
It's a machete!
I don't think I have...
I don't have inventory space, so you gotta pick it up.
You gotta pick it up.
I don't have inventory space.
Let me know when you...
Let me know.
Do you need more?
Alright, let's go.
By the way, I also have an axe, by the way.
I had an axe, by the way.
lol Wait, there's houses here.
Is this a village?
Wait, there's houses here.
There's a village here.
Is this a new world?
This is a new world.
Do you think they have AKs?
Is this...
Oh.
Sorry, I meant...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just thinking...
I know.
All I'm saying is that they won't know if we never...
You know, it's not a sin if they don't see us use it.
Yeah.
lol
I think...
We get a...
We make a separate home in the middle.
And then we can swap clothes.
And...
Swap clothes and like items.
So we make a little mini house there.
That's just for us too.
You know, when we feel like we wanna...
Know what it's like to be in the new world.
Yeah, Freya was Hannah Montana.
Odin came to us in a dream.
And...
No, no, we can say that!
We were spies.
Odin came to us in a dream.
And he wanted us to spy on the new world.
And we had to immerse ourselves in the new world.
And he wanted us to get the best of both worlds.
Best of both worlds.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes!
We're just trying to live the best of both worlds.
lol
Horse.
But isn't that somebody else's horse?
This is literally...
This is literally you just stole from an artist.
lol
lol Okay, well my horse is stuck you were never gonna get that horse back
Oh my god, they can follow.
Yeah, you can tap the horse.
No, wait, get the horse.
Wait.
Hi.
Hello.
Wait, is that not the bike gang?
I don't know, I don't know.
I'll get inside anyways.
I thought you said this is safe.
The bike gang?
The people to your left, are they not the bike gang on the bikes?
Maybe this is safe, they don't know the bike gang.
You guys never encountered the bike gang?
I'm looking at bikes.
Oh my god, this is a safe place.
Are you guys part of the bike gang?
No, no, we're trying.
Beyond this land, there's savages out there.
They're known as the bike gang.
It's very scary.
What do they do to people?
They ride around in bikes.
They make you pick up their shit.
And if they don't kill you, they make you pick up horse poop.
And then they say eat it.
And you've never lived beyond this town, right?
Have you ever ventured out of this town, Mammoth?
Yes, and I got murdered.
Yes, exactly.
Never leave this town.
This is the only safe place out there.
I'm not planning.
Are you gonna make me pick it up?
We're teaching you the horrors of the bike gang.
So you never have to experience it, just like us.
Oh my god, Da Vinci!
Did you make this?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What?
It's Leslie and Jon Snow.
Oh!
Is that like...
Holding hands.
Is that... Are they like dating?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I can see it.
I see it.
And then Jamie Lancaster is sitting in the bush waiting.
Waiting for who?
For Leslie.
She's with Jon Snow right now.
Oh, so it's like a little love triangle.
I see.
I can see it.
Oh, that's some drama going on.
What is this piece called?
Yeah, yeah.
What's this artwork called?
Um...
The Turmoil of Freelanding.
Of Freehold, sorry.
Of Freehold.
It's pretty lewd that they're holding hands, too.
And Leslie's not even wearing gloves.
Yeah, you know.
It's really lewd.
True.
Yeah, she's holding hands without protection.
Yeah, yeah.
What is with that?
That's how much she loves him.
True, true.
Here, here, here.
All the way from L4.
All the way over here.
We gotta put you at our house, though.
Told you.
What?
We have safe haven here.
We have safe haven here?
This is my brother, Nix.
He's a man of the clergy.
The clergy?
He's a priest?
He's religious?
Yeah, the clergy.
Is he the new gods?
Whoa, what's wrong?
What happened to him?
What happened?
Wait, wait.
Skull, skull, skull.
We need a skull.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just in case one of us runs into him.
Okay, we'll put your bag over here.
Do you need a cloth?
I have cloth.
I have four cloth.
Hey, hey, hey.
Get out of my TC.
What?
Toki, four cloth is not enough.
That's the only cloth I have.
Four cloth?
That's the only one I have.
Nix, I'm gonna cook 19 bear meat in your metal frog, if you will.
I have nine more bear meat, too.
We have to tell you.
We've been adopted by a group called the Lurklings.
But we... but the biker gang lives... the biker gangs live nearby.
We're not allowed to use the metal?
They say that on the third day, we'll be granted our special wish.
We don't know what that special wish is.
The biker gang, they came up to me like, yo, do you like Dick?
And I said, yeah, and they just left me alone.
Did you guys hear that?
Did you guys... I don't know if you guys heard that.
The biker gang came up to him and was like, did you like Dick?
And then the guy said, yes, and then he rode off.
Speech 100.
Speech 100 right there.
Is there a sleeping bag?
Whoa.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, really?
Nice.
Thank you.
Is this mine?
Oh, this is mine, right?
Wait, I wanna, wait.
I, I, I changed the name.
This is my, my new life.
My new life.
I'm just trying to live my life, guys.
I don't wanna, the biker gang fucked me up and now I don't wanna live through that again.
I don't wanna go through that experience again.
Alright, where should we go?
Should we explore this village?
I'm gonna explore, I'm gonna explore the village, Umi.
I wanna see what technology is like.
I wanna know what it's like to have metal.
I wanna know.
I wanna know what it's like to have it.
Umi, Umi, Plow's here.
Plow's here.
They're here, they're here.
Mother of hoes.
Hello, it is I.
It's like the Amish take that one day in normalcy.
Am I the Amish?
I feel like the Amish.
We're the Amish of this land.
It's like that thing where they, they're, they're like, they're like, they're allowed to go spend a year.
They're allowed to spend a year outside the civilization and get to choose to live in the Amish land or, or like live in the city.
It's like a specific thing they do for a year.
I noticed that you're, you're holding his hand without protection.
He's hazed.
Hazed.
He's been working since, since the, the first kind of five minutes this all started.
That's crazy.
I have a ticket.
Wow, it's a bear doing the city.
There's bears in the city.
Oh my God, there's a train.
How was there?
My curse, my curse joined, joined.
Oh, there's a train underground.
A train comes by, a train, it comes by.
Underground train.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh my God, look at this art gallery.
Oh my God, it's so beautiful.
I knew I was here.
There we go, I stopped it.
You have to jump off, jump off.
You have to jump off.
I wanna explore, I'm gonna explore the village a little bit.
I wanna know what's going on in this village.
I like how there's camera on the artwork right here.
I like how they put camera on the fucking painting.
Wow!
Oh my God!
No.
Oh, please save me.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for saving me.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
I couldn't see him.
I couldn't see him, I have no light.
Thank you so much.
Oh, it's so dark.
I'm afraid of the dark.
How is there boys?
There's a nightclub?
There's a fucking nightclub?
Bro, I am the Amish.
Oh my God, hello.
Oh my God, you're working on nightclub?
When will it be opening?
When's the grand opening?
Oh.
It's exclusive?
How do we get on the list?
Anyone?
Oh, VIP section.
It's for those very important people.
Oh, and you can look down at the peasants too.
The little commoners.
Oh.
Oh, you thought of everything.
Oh, I can't wait, I can't wait.
I'm gonna be the first one here.
Can't wait to go to this nightclub.
Yeah.
Thanks for showing me the nightclub.
Can't wait.
Oh, Gumi.
Gumi?
I was looking at the nightclub, they have a VIP section.
It's still being worked on.
Yeah, I'm gonna fucking party.
I am the Amish.
The Amish that went here for after a year.
Oh my God, this is where I go.
This is where I'm gonna go.
Oh my God, hey.
Yeah, we are!
And they have like a year where they go to the city and spend a year in the city and partying and stuff.
That's us right now.
We're Rum Springer.
Yeah, this is Rum Springer.
What else is in the city?
You wanna visit the Blood God?
Are we visiting the Blood God?
We can go gambling!
I have scrap on me, I have scrap on me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I don't have scrap with me, I'm poor, I'm so poor.
I'm so poor.
Oh, there's a gambling leaderboard?
There's already a thousand for- Holy shit, people have been gambling, gambling.
I'm following you!
Wait, these are free horses?
No, they're not, they're not, they're not.
You gotta pay for them.
You gotta buy them.
Hey, welcome back!
Thanks for the skull!
Your skull saved our lives!
We almost died!
Yeah!
You saved our life!
I don't think he appreciates it, Umi.
I think he's a little angry that you killed him.
Two lives is better than one!
Let's go gambling!
Oh, you guys are gambling too?
Oh,
I have to wait till next spin?
FUUUUUCK!
Oh,
I think the bike gang- The biker gang, I think the biker gang hit the church.
Here,
here's three scrap.
I gave three!
I kept dropping them!
Who took the horses?
Who?
Who's they?
They took your horses too?!
That's what- that's- gambling's a problem.
No!
No way!
Yes!
Yeah!
I'm making it rain!
Like twenty dollars.
You lost twenty?!
I'll give you two.
Desert.
I didn't put it on twenty, man!
That's what you get.
That's an I.O.U.
of interest rates.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I'm so good at gambling.
Guys, I have another stream in like an hour and a half.
And I'm gambling right now.
Come on.
Give me a purple.
Purple, purple, purple, purple, purple, purple, purple.
Blue, blue, blue, blue!
We're getting down!
Oh my god, did I get anything?
That- no!
I didn't win anything!
I'm done.
Um, I gotta quit.
I gotta quit before it- I gotta quit before it- before I fuck up.
Okay.
How do I do this?
How do I spin this?
How do you spin this, guys?
Oh, here.
How do I spin it?
Scrap or spin?
A- I need A?!
Is it A?
Actually?
Oh, you get eight spins.
Oh!
Wait, but how do you...
How do you click it?
Wait, is it- Oh, wait.
Oh, I need eight.
Okay.
Three, four, five.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Oh my god, that's so many scraps.
Oh my god, this is how they get you.
This is...
Okay.
There you go.
This is how they get you.
This is- Oh, this is...
This is how they get you hooked.
This is it.
Let's go gambling!
This is so hard!
This is how they get you.
This is it.
This is how they hook you in.
The house always wins.
I give up.
No, if I give up now, I'll never- Oh my gosh, I'm giving it up before I hit it big.
Maybe the next spin will be it.
The next spin.
This next spin will be it.
You got it.
You can't stop.
Yes!
I knew!
I knew it.
I lost it all.
I won it all back.
I can't lose.
What is this?
I cannot lose.
Toki, can I have some?
Can I have some?
Uh-oh.
I don't know why, but I couldn't hit him.
That's weird.
It was like I- Haku, I think there's something wrong with your mic.
Oh, whoa, what?
What?
Okay, I feel like there needs to be more light here.
I feel like there needs to be more light here.
I should not have a torch on to see where I am.
Alright, play for me and I'll give you scrap.
That was beautiful.
Here, take one scrap.
Now, go feed your fucking addiction.
Yeah.
Alright, we're leaving.
You're not coming back.
Oh, hey, it's daytime.
You wanna visit the Blood God church?
Let's see what they're up to.
Do you think he'll give us a gun?
I wanna see what my skin looks like.
I just wanna know what my skin looks like.
That's it.
Hey,
what happened?
Did you encounter the bike gang?
Was it from the bike gang?
It's always the bike gang!
Every time!
Dina, it's on site.
Lady Dima?
Who's that?
Lady Dina?
Dina?
Dima?
I don't know.
And Winnie.
It's on site.
Oh yeah, no, Winnie for sure.
Winnie's for sure.
I know they're in the bike gang.
If they ever pull up on you, you have to give them a skull.
Yeah, yeah.
You see that body up there?
Harvest the skull.
Yeah, take their skull and then you'll be fine.
They just need skulls.
That's all they want.
That's the only way to protect yourself.
You just got to...
Take this person's skull and you'll be fine.
Did you get a skull?
Okay, well, you got to find more people and take their skull.
Alright, I'm gonna go... Let's go to the church.
Oh my God!
There's so many...
They got killed by an arrow!
Winnie's!
Wait, this is Winnie's!
He got one of them!
Revenge!
Take this!
Yeah, and that!
Here, Jiho.
Have this skull.
I have a key.
Why do I... What do I do with a key?
It was on their body.
I picked it up from their body.
No, no, no.
I have a key from somebody else.
I don't know what it's for though.
I just said I picked it up from their body.
Oh, Jiho, am I seeing you tomorrow?
You picked me up from the airport.
There's a random door here.
Oh wait, yeah.
Yes, I do.
What if I starve?
What if I fucking starve, guys?
I need... I need all these pumpkins.
You don't know that!
I can starve right now!
Hi!
Whoa!
Hello.
What do you think about religion?
Are you a religious person?
I think religion is pretty cool and that there's only...
And there's only one God in this world.
And what God is it?
And it is a God that everybody believes in.
Okay.
Alright.
Are you... Are you interested in being part of something larger than yourself?
Larger than myself?
What does that mean?
Yeah.
It means...
Are we supposed to be...
Being a part of something that could have great ramifications later on.
And how... How is that?
Okay.
First, you have to play rock, paper, scissors against Kira.
Congratulations.
I did it!
You beat my first loss.
Come with me.
Your first loss?
Am I...
Is it destiny?
I was...
Come on.
Congratulations.
Good old rock.
Nothing beats...
Guys, I think I fucked up.
This is our church.
This is...
This is where we have regular sermons.
This is Gimmick.
Hello.
Why are your names red?
I was told that red means bad.
Gimmick had to defend himself.
Gimmick was forced to defend himself in a big attack.
It's not his fault.
I see.
But you lived though.
For what we believe in here.
Is Gimmick a part of the church?
Yes.
I am an acolyte, but...
Gimmick was baptized.
I was baptized, but they're still crafting my medallion.
Were you circumcised?
Oh, yes.
I did it myself.
Oh, yeah?
Like, now?
Just then?
That's a very...
Would you like some food?
Are you hungry?
I was feeding a hungry.
Feel that slip out.
So, what do I win for...
What do I win for winning Rock, Paper, Scissors?
Thank you.
You get to join the church.
I get to join the church?
Isn't that great?
Yeah, you get to be a part of the church.
Did everybody else win Rock, Paper, Scissors to join the church too?
So, you have no idea how big an honor it is to be able to join the church.
Oh, my God.
That's a big honor.
But nobody else defeated him before.
How are you guys part of the church?
Well...
Listen, it's very complicated to explain.
It's a church business.
You'll just have to take our word for it.
Oh, so recruitment was changed later on, right?
Recruitment was just changed later on.
It's a counterclockwise-esque rotation with a semi-MLM system built in.
If you refer two people to the church, you'll be entitled to 50% of their church donations.
And if the two people you refer to the church, refer two people to the church, you'll be entitled to 25% of the donations of those two people.
Wait, I know somebody.
Gumi, have you heard about this church?
She's shy.
She's shy right now.
We have an exciting opportunity for you.
Come here, we have an exciting opportunity.
So how do you join this church?
Really?
It's part of your earnings, yeah.
Oh my god, thank you!
The more people you refer to the church, the more you stand to earn.
Oh, that sounds so exciting!
That sounds like a bargain right there.
I can become, like, rich by being in this church.
Yes, and you wake up with a sense of purpose.
Every morning you wake up knowing today will be a meaningful day.
How do you taunt?
I have no idea.
You just use your mouth.
You don't join the church, Gumi.
Simply to get rich.
The church is so much more than that.
What else do you have here, then?
What did you call me?
That's not my name.
We have blood!
Blood is what we have!
I have blood in my body.
That's not my name.
Sometimes we have more.
Blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood, blood...
Blood, we've got blood.
We slip it in.
What?
A little taste of blood goes a long way with the blood...
Yeah, just blood, right?
Just blood, right?
Just blood.
Yes, blood.
Yeah, of course, blood.
Yeah.
The fluid of mankind.
It will be on the floor when you slip on it.
That's what he was intending to say with that.
What color is the fluid?
What color is it?
Oh, praise be, praise be.
It's now Gummiho.
How does one join this church?
It's Gummiho, it's Gummi, Gummiho.
This is Clayton's erotic roleplay.
This is beautiful, beautiful voice.
Oh, the beat, he's dropping a beat right now.
He's been blessed by the gods.
Hit it.
Hallelujah.
I
got it.
Hit it.
Yeah.
That is crazy.
We should get, we should go here more often.
I got it.
Metaphorically, of course, metaphorically.
The slip into your heart spirit.
Wait, wait, wait.
Slipping into my, not the back door, right?
Can you use the front door?
I don't want to use the back door.
Bro,
I think I joined the wrong religion.
You know what?
Even the blood god sold out, at least the, at least the tracks on fire.
At least, at least the tracks on fire.
How do you emote, guys?
How do you emote?
Is that in the, is that in the book of the blood god?
Where can I purchase the book of the blood god?
Praise be.
Wait, so who is true?
Ooh.
I don't know.
They don't know.
They didn't see anything, guys.
Hey, Blau.
Hey, Sir Blau.
We got skulls!
Hey!
Hey there!
I'm up here!
Oh, really?
Chip!
Oh my god, dingles!
I did.
They never saw me.
How'd you do?
You look good.
Every orifice was filled with arrows.
And they dragged my hooks up to the back of my motorcycle and dragged me through the mountains.
We didn't get caught, guys.
We didn't get caught.
Hey, how are you?
Guys, we didn't get caught.
We didn't get caught.
What's going on?
He offered the pumpkin seeds.
I don't know what you guys are talking about, man.
Yes, the blood god brings me back so often.
Wait, was that Charlie?
Of course, his name is Juice Man.
Of course.
I was not involved in that.
I just showed up.
Quest this, quest that.
You know what?
You got an itchy trigger finger.
Those are some accusations right there.
Is that true?
Do not shed blood in front of a holy site.
Rangers, this is the blood god's territory.
Ride back to the ice fort.
I'm shitting out stone hatchets, oh my lord.
It's time, it's time.
Onwards, brethren.
Are we going back to the fortress?
I need you to acquire horses.
Watch your six, you Australian fuck.
Yeah, yeah, whatever.
Where the fuck do we get horses?
Wow, shit, okay.
Oh,
there's a boar in front of us, by the way.
There's a boar in front of us.
Oh, there's a metal horse.
Harvest!
We do this London style, brothers.
Harvesting!
Harvest the boar again.
We are the lurkers.
We are the ice fortress.
We bow to no kings.
Ice fortress.
I've dropped off 80 scrap at your abode, Mr. Bo.
I left it with brother Neeks.
80 scrap?
Hell yeah.
You should come by later to gamble.
You have needs of the devil's metal?
Here, Mr. Bo.
Eat up.
We do actually have need of the devil's metal.
Under your bike.
Oh, his inventory is full.
It's okay, you don't need shoes.
You don't need shoes.
Shoes is just aesthetic.
Let those toes free.
Who's this?
Who goes there?
Oh, Neutron!
What's up, dude?
Hey, baby, what's up?
I can't get over the fucking change of talking.
Who goes there?
Yo, what's up, bro?
I can't.
I fucking can't.
Yeah?
Maybe he's not going to be...
Alright.
We gotta get the rock?
Alright, let's go to the rock.
We shall walk.
Yeah?
I like the idea.
I like the idea very much.
Oh, you saw horses this way?
Is there horses there?
That is...
No, that's not a horse.
That's just wood.
There has to be horses near...
Somebody has to ride a horse near us.
Yeah, but I think they just kept going, Goomy.
I think they just kept running.
Let's just keep going until we find somebody and take the horse.
Guys, I can't work on an AK.
I might be banished from Bahala.
I have to mooch off somebody else's AK.
If somebody else makes an AK...
and then gives it to me...
then that's different.
Oh, shit.
He's dead.
We gotta...
Yeah, we gotta...
Wait, is that a horse?
Is that a horse?
He's looking at me.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
His gun is insane.
Oh, my God.
His gun is fucking insane.
Wait, there's another horse.
There's another.
Two horses.
No.
Hey, we're here to trade.
We're here to trade.
We're just here to trade.
We need him a bit closer, guys.
We need him.
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
How did he know?
Wait.
Oh, he's shooting behind us.
He's trying to snipe.
And he's going back.
He's a coward.
He went back to the safe zone.
He's not a real fight.
He's not a real man.
He doesn't fight fair.
As I say, we're traitors.
We don't use cheesy tactics like that.
He lacks honor.
Oh, that was my bet, isn't that?
I think we should have our bows like sheathed so they don't know.
Behind us?
Where?
Oh, he's like hiding.
I mean, his name was Red.
I don't think we...
I think he's killed us.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright,
we got to...
We're almost there.
Where is everybody?
Everybody's back.
He lurks in the bushes ready for an ambush.
Alright, as soon as we finish the last meeting.
Whatever the meeting is at the rocks.
We're going to call it.
Because I want to rest a little bit before my...
Before Silent Hill.
That's a scientist.
It's okay.
He'll live.
He'll survive.
He is strong.
Wait, he's here.
He's back.
Okay, I need to know the drop off for this.
I need to know.
I can't believe he's trying to do a hit and run.
Where is he?
I don't see him.
Wait, did Gumi die?
Or did she road forward?
Oh.
Where was she?
Did she die?
Maybe we shouldn't have shot him, guys.
Maybe...
Maybe we shouldn't have shot him.
Maybe that was a mistake.
Did she die?
I think she did.
I don't see her.
Yeah, we definitely should not have tried to shoot that guy.
That guy was...
He was...
A little scary.
He seemed like he knew what he was doing, chat.
One day I'll know what an AK is like.
One day I'll know what it's like to hold my gun.
Yeah, I'm heading back right now.
I think she bled out.
Wait, whose bed is this?
It's not my bed.
This is a cute bed.
It's pretty cute.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god, look at our house!
Now it has a pee pee tower!
It has a pee pee tower now!
Let's go!
Alright, let's go in.
We're at our place.
My old body is still there.
Let me put some stuff away.
I have too much stuff that I don't need.
Oh wait.
I need my arrows.
And then I'll put this away.
And then...
The what bucket?
Oh yeah, I wanna keep all of my scrap.
Did you live?
You lived!
You survived!
Oh shit!
I don't think we should have shot that guy.
No!
No medal!
Is this a stable?
Oh my god!
Look at all our horses!
All three of them!
They don't know.
Wait, he's over here!
He's looking at us!
I'm not, I'm just uh...
I am, I'm not shooting!
We're not shooting!
We're here in your house.
I'm nice, I'm actually nice.
Do you remember the last time this happened?
It's a peaceful offering.
He brings metal material!
He's trying to take the shot!
Oh my god, it's all metal!
It's so disgusting!
Take a shot, take the shot.
Take the shot.
He shot you.
He shot you though.
Oh my god!
Wow.
Oh my!
Thank you so much, sir.
Welcome to the land of the free people.
Welcome.
I almost took the shot.
I wanted to do it.
I- I wanted to assassinate him.
I almost did it.
You're getting louder!
The voices are getting louder!
Oh.
Sorry, I may have- Hold on.
This is very awkward.
Sorry about that.
What's up?
20 minutes ago, y'all were in front of our kingdom, okay?
I don't want to hear this.
I don't want to hear this nonsense.
We just came back.
That's a good point.
Both of y'all were right in front of our kingdom.
Everything was fine and dandy.
Now all of a sudden, you're upset.
Calm down, guys.
Calm down.
What's the evidence?
Oh my goodness.
But it's made out of metal, sir.
You broke one.
Oh my god.
I don't know if we can move all of that.
Does it not burn your hand?
We need to build magic.
It does not.
Oh, you're gonna go just do that?
No, man.
Oh yes, that's correct for now.
I saw a king.
I think you have to come up with the horse.
I'm simply head of the kingdom.
I'm an acting king at the moment.
Your clan is beefing because they walked up to us and now they're upset we walked up to them.
This is our home.
Why are you guys building all the way out here?
It's the frost.
This is where we live.
Did you not hear how he talked to our king?
Did you not hear how he talked to the king?
Where did he go?
We get a horse!
We get his horse!
That's right!
Yes!
I took the shot!
Harvest him!
I have the bone!
Did you get it?
The skull of blueprint.
It's time.
We got the king.
The battle is won.
How do I get off?
I got another horse in the collection!
I got one stuck.
You can lead them out.
You can make them follow you and they'll walk back.
I tried.
He's not one of us.
There.
I'm trying.
How do I get him in?
Oh no!
You can bring this other horse in.
Let me take the arrows off his ass too.
He wants to be there actually.
I'm taking the arrows.
He wants to be here.
Don't worry, I can fix it.
Bring all the horse to the stables!
All horses to the stables!
What is happening?
We just received a bunch of new ones.
Listen, this horse...
We're gonna have to break the ramps.
What if they try to...
Why did they try to steal our horses?
Can they not break our stables and steal our horses?
They're going to come back stronger.
These guys are going to come back for revenge.
We'll just keep him there.
I'll fix this.
We can just keep him there.
Here you go, I repaired the horse.
Yeah, but they don't have anything anymore.
Don't worry, I'll scout out.
Alright, listen.
Ladies and sirs, listen.
Who needs this contraption metal that I have on my hand?
Who needs it?
What is that?
We do not use metal here, dragon.
We will have to in this war.
If the devil comes to attack Valhalla, we'll fight him with devil magic.
No, no, no, sir.
No.
Oh my goodness.
Who needs this contraption in my hand?
Who wants this for battle?
Drop it.
Because I have two of them.
It is not our way.
Drop them all.
This is not our way.
You know what?
At least they can't take the horse because it's stuck.
Didn't Blau said he had an announcement to make at the rock?
What was it?
Do you have an arrow in your butt cheek, Elam?
Stand still.
Can you take it out?
I got it.
I want to know before I go.
I need to know before I go.
I literally was like...
I was like, alright.
I'm going to wait until this announcement.
And then I go home.
And then I rest.
Can
you let me in?
Oh, yeah.
Please.
Thank you.
Oh, I think it was...
Is this metal?
Oh, I actually took metal here.
I actually took metal.
I actually took it, yeah.
We were harvesting the body.
Oh, wait.
There's a stack.
You missed the stack.
Oh, yeah.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
He had more metal.
Who has the metal?
We need the metal.
Please.
Give it back to him.
Whoever looted the body.
Give him the metal back.
I got an idea, guys.
I got an idea.
To be fair, I didn't think he'd keep track of how many metals he had.
Hahaha.
Now, no one will know it was me.
Here.
You can take this one.
Come here.
Take this one.
But they can ride.
Hahaha.
Wait, guys.
How do we unstick this horse?
We can't.
We have to break the ramp.
We need to break the ramp.
Yeah, we got to get rid of the ramp.
Yeah, we can't even get rid of the ramp.
Too late.
Yeah, it's real.
Well, we'll give him a different horse.
And then Stable Master Demo can...
Hahaha.
Yeah, let's get the horses out.
Get them out.
Get the horses out.
Let's go, Lito.
So...
Alright.
Why did we give them back a horse?
Hahaha.
They did it.
They left without the medal.
See, they didn't care about the medal.
I gotta keep my medal.
Hahaha.
Wait.
What did H-June said?
I thought we were their allies.
Who killed the horse?
It was for the gods.
It has been fixed.
Who took my chimpkin?
Who did it?
Guess what?
Your what?
I have no chimpkin.
Liza, you took Kevin...
I did not, I did not, I did not.
Give him a bag right now.
Give Kevin a bag.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
I've never heard of a...
Alright, I gotta go now.
I gotta rest.
I have another...
I have to go.
I have another stream.
I shall go rest for another day.
I'll see you all later.
I shall rest and dream of another life.
I shall dream another life when I hit the bed.
Where's my bed?
Yeah?
I have Silent Hill in 30 minutes.
Yes?
Thank you.
Thank you, Sir Blau.
I shall dream.
I shall dream of a city that never sleeps.
Yes.
It's like a picture that's forever.
I shall see you all the next day and dream of many things in another world.
Good night, everybody.
Good night.
Thank you.
Bye.
What do you mean?
It's a...
It's PDA.
You know me and PDA.
People are watching.
Alright, bye-bye.
That was fun.
I had a lot of fun.
That was really fun.
I hope all you guys were able to get drops while playing.
I'll try to do more.
I'll try to do some gorilla rush streams while we're here since I do have drops.
So, we'll see.
We'll see whenever I do have time so people can get my drop.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for coming.
I do have Silent Hill 2 in 30 minutes on YouTube.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on the YouTube so you can check me out there.
I usually tweet out whenever I'm live on Twitch and whenever I'm doing gorilla streams on Twitch.
So, you can check me out.
You should follow me on Twitter to find out when I'm live especially if it's a gorilla stream for Rust.
Also, I have merch!
I have merch!
If you guys didn't know, I have my very own PC case from Hyatt as well as keycaps.
Apparently, the shipping...
Have you pre-ordered them before?
You already pre-ordered it?
You should be receiving them now or this upcoming week or next week.
I hope you guys got your gun.
I hope you guys got the gun if you have.
I hope you guys got it.
But yes, check out my merch.
I have a gamer subs code as well.
Subscribe to me on YouTube because that's where I usually stream.
Hey guys, I am gonna...
Yes, you can still order it.
You can still order the PC.
I don't know what... I think it's like exclamation point Hyatt.
Also, I have a concert!
I have a concert coming up!
It's our next surprise guest.
We do have one more final surprise guest.
So, yeah!
Check all those out!
Everything all there.
As always, everybody, say hi, join the posh check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed or watch Silent Hill 2.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!